Listener, what are you doing? Are you driving? Are you walking? Are you jogging? Are you banging around in a subway looking at weird people and now you're listening to a weird person? Well, guess what? I'm sitting alone. I've got headphones on and you know, we're just in this weird space together while we're waiting for Sean and Will to get their crap together and grab a microphone. Until then I'm gonna play a little music for you, a little robot music. All right, here we go. Welcome to Smartless. I'm back home.
听众朋友，你们在干什么？在开车吗？在走路吗？在慢跑吗？在地铁里挤来挤去，看着周围奇怪的人，然后现在在听一个怪人说话？好吧，猜怎么着？我正一个人坐着。我戴着耳机，你知道的，我们俩就在这个奇怪的空间里呆在一起，等着肖恩和威尔把他们的烂摊子收拾好，拿起麦克风。在此之前，我要为你们放点音乐，一点机器人音乐。好了，我们开始吧。欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋》（Smartless）。我回家了。
I'm back home. I'm feeling really good about it. You don't sound good. You sound a little bored and tired and not into the sash today. This is we're having a sash. We're having a pod sash. Okay. Listener.
我回家了。我感觉好极了。你听起来可不太好。你听起来有点无聊、疲惫，今天对闲聊（sesh）没啥兴趣。我们正在闲聊。我们在开播客闲聊（pod sesh）。好吧，听众朋友。
Singular by this point. Thank you for your support, listener, by the way. Yeah, we really appreciate keeping this this boat float. Yeah. Jason dropped Sash on the on the group chat. The group text says Sashi and then Sashie and then he went Sashie and then he said it's super fun. It's a short and and fun for a session. Right. And we all know it. We all know Sesh.
听到这儿就剩你一个听众了。顺便说一句，谢谢你的支持，听众朋友。是的，我们真的很感谢你让这条船继续在大海航行。杰森在群聊里抛出了“Sesh”这个词。群发短信上写着“Sashi”，然后是“Sashie”，接着他又打出“Sashie”，然后他说这超级有趣。这很简短，而且聚会很有趣。对吧。我们都知道。我们都知道Sesh。
But of course, he's the bit is the bit is that nobody's ever used Sesh or Sesh. I love Sesh has been used, but I'm think I'm first probably on Earth with Sesh. Yeah. So you might be, are we going to, are we talking about a new sweatshirt? You know what? You don't need a smart list with Sashi. You know what? The stupid, get a new Sashi.
但当然，这个梗的妙处在于，从来没人用过“Sesh”或“Sashi”。我喜欢“Sesh”被使用过，但我想我可能是地球上第一个用“Sashi”的人。好吧，你可能还真是，我们要，我们在谈论一件新卫衣吗？你知道吗？你不需要带有Sashi的Smartless。你知道吗？太蠢了，弄个新的Sashi吧。
Join the Sashi. That's a good idea. The stupidest short I have that I forget who gave it to me, but I will not stop it is presh. Oh, presh always. I won't stop. I appreciate it. I love presh.
加入Sashi。这主意不错。我有个最蠢的缩写，我忘了是谁教我的，但我会一直用下去，那就是“presh”。哦，永远的presh。我不会停下来的。我很感激。我爱presh。
It is the prettiest. Do she she like appreciate? Yeah. Yeah. Short for appreciate it. So somebody does something you go, ah, presh dog. Oh, God. It's so fast. You used to get so mad at me for shortening words. Oh, it just because I just I love typing it to presh. Because I will put the little, the little, what do you call it, hyphen there?
这是最可爱的。Do she she（她她）就像 appreciate（感激）？对。对。appreciate 的缩写。所以别人做了什么，你就说，啊，presh 哥。哦，天哪。这太快了。你以前总是为我缩写单词而生我的气。哦，那只是因为我，我喜欢把它打成 presh。因为我会加上那个小小的，那个小小的，你把它叫什么，连字符？
Or no, no, that the, what is it? The apostrophe. Oh, God. The brain. The brain shuts down after 330 for me and we're now at 408. Yeah, I mean, we are, we're pushing dangerously close to, to gummyville.
或者不，不，那个，是什么来着？撇号。哦，天哪。我的大脑。我一过三点半大脑就罢工了，现在已经四点零八分了。是啊，我的意思是，我们，我们正危险地逼近软糖镇（gummyville）。
I mean, I mean, I read out the outskirts of gummyville. I don't do that for work, bro. I know, dude. I know. Just this is the end of my protein shake right there. I'm on the backside of a workout. I'm fresh.
我的意思是，我的意思是，我来到了软糖镇的边缘。我不为工作做那个，兄弟。我知道，老兄。我知道。这正是我蛋白奶昔的最后一点。我刚健完身。我状态正佳。
Oh, this is me peaking. Oh, God, this is your peak. I'm peaking. Look at the hair. Speaking of peak, my happiness is about to peak. And what is it a week and a half, Sean? Yeah, because Sean's coming home. I'm so excited.
哦，这是我的巅峰期。哦，天哪，这是你的巅峰。我在巅峰期。看看这头发。说到巅峰，我的快乐马上就要达到巅峰了。还有多久，一个半星期，肖恩？对，因为肖恩要回家了。我太兴奋了。
I know I feel the same way when I'm home. You know what we did today? We packed boxes and we borrowed this old luggage carrier, you know, like a bellhop uses, to put the boxes on and walk them down the sidewalk to FedEx. You did. Where did you get one of the little holes, one of the little... There's one in the basement here in the building. In the building.
我知道，我在家的时候也是这种感觉。你知道我们今天做什么了吗？我们打包了箱子，还借了一个旧行李车，你知道的，就像酒店行李员用的那种，把箱子放上去，沿着人行道推到联邦快递（FedEx）。你们真的去了。你在哪儿弄到那个小洞，其中一个小……大楼的地下室里有一个。在这栋大楼里。
Yeah. But I mean, the site of me and Scotty pushing this thing, sweating our ass up, down the sidewalk. Yeah, it's like a bad opening credits to a sitcom. Did you hit it? It totally is. It totally is. It totally is. Wait, where was it, Sean? Where's the FedEx office?
对。但我的意思是，我和斯科蒂推着这玩意儿，在人行道上热得要死的样子。是的，就像情景喜剧里糟糕的开场白。你拍下来了吗？完全是的。完全是的。完全是的。等等，在哪儿，肖恩？联邦快递办事处在哪里？
It's just a couple of things over. It's a couple of blocks. Well, Avenue or blocks. No, like blocks, like blocks. But we wield it inside the store. Sure. So we have the luggage carrier. I should do that when I live downtown,
就在附近几步路。就几个街区。到底是大道还是街区？不，就像街区，就像街区。但我们把它推进了店里。当然。所以我们有这个行李车。我住在闹市区时应该这么做，
when I live downtown in the West Village, there was a FedEx right on Lee Roy Street and I lived and I could come out of the back of my building. Anyway, I would come a full, almost big long block and I go across the street with the thing into the FedEx. What kind of thing? Did you have like a little red wagon or something like that? Or do you have?
当我住在西村（West Village）闹市区时，勒鲁瓦街（Lee Roy Street）上就有一家联邦快递，我住在那儿，我可以从我大楼的后门出来。总之，我会走完整整一大段长街，然后带着那东西过马路进联邦快递。什么东西？你是有个小红旅行车还是别的什么？还是说你有？
No, I lived the same thing, luggage cart from the building that had, you could put, you could hang stuff above. They all the buildings have them in New York, you have to. I didn't know that. I didn't know we had one. Oh, man, you're going to love playing it there. Dude, you're going to love Planet Earth.
不，我住的地方也一样，用的是大楼里的行李车，你可以把东西挂在上边。纽约所有的建筑都有这个，你必须得有。我不知道。我不知道我们有一个。哦，天哪，你会在那里玩得很开心的。老兄，你会喜欢地球的。
I know you've been up to, your head's been up in space, hoping it's real, right? I asked for a dollie. We got right now, Sean. Sean, where are we at right now with you with alien, with God? I, I, I, I, because it feels like it's really come like, right? Sean, it's a hundred people. He's talking from the government now. It's a hundred hundred. Are you going to Congress? Are you going to do any stuff like just going like, it's real. You guys, Scotty watching C-SPAN in the back room right now and bring a gavill for no reason. Sean Hayes from television and film. Go ahead,
我知道你一直在，你的脑子一直在太空里，希望它是真的，对吧？我想要个手推车。肖恩，我们现在跟你聊到外星人和上帝了。我，我，我，因为感觉它真的发生了，对吧？肖恩，有一百个人。他现在是代表政府在说话。有一百个人。你要去国会吗？你要去做点什么，比如去说“这是真的”吗？你们看，斯科蒂在后面的房间里看着C-SPAN（美国国会频道），无缘无故地拿出一把法官槌。来自电视和电影界的肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）。请说，
Sean. It's real, you guys. All right. That's all I got to say. Guys and just a gavill. Gav, everybody pay attention. So wait, they're like, why do you have a gavill? Just outgavill them. But did you see the press conference like a month or two ago where the guys like said basically, no, it was all over the news. It was, I did. That they're real. I saw parts of it. It was all over the news. It was. I did. That they're real. It didn't lead the news. It was kind of like in the last 30 seconds when they put kind of uplifting shots of, no, no, this was like a big, well conquering diseases and stuff.
肖恩。这是真的，伙计们。好吧。这就是我要说的。伙计们，还有一把法官槌。法官槌，大家注意。等等，他们会问：你为什么拿着法官槌？直接用法官槌压过他们。但你有没有看一个月或两个月前的那个新闻发布会，有人说基本上，不，这上了所有新闻。确实，我看了。他们是真的。我看了一部分。这上了所有新闻。是的。确实如此。他们是真的。但这并不是头条新闻。它有点像最后30秒里播放的那些振奋人心的镜头，不，不，这是一个关于战胜疾病之类的大型……
No, this is a big government press conference about. We've heard some crazy stuff. I heard some crazy stuff in the last week from a dude I know talking about aliens and their existence. I don't want to get too deep into their name people, but it's like pretty crazy. Oh, apparently they're here among us and all this. Yes, it's right. Yes, but we even know which, which square you were pointing at. That was what they don't say it. We allow. Hey, guys, the preach, preach. Yeah, preach. I'm trying to protect. I'm trying to protect the innocent, dude. You know why? Because snitches get stitches. Okay.
不，这是一个关于……的大型政府新闻发布会。我们听到了很多疯狂的事情。过去一周我从一个认识的人那里听到了一些疯狂的事情，谈到了外星人及其存在。我不想过多谈论他们的名字，但这太疯狂了。哦，显然他们就在我们中间，诸如此类。是的，没错。是的，甚至我们知道你当时在指哪个方块。这就是他们没说出来的。我们允许。嘿，伙计们，说得好，说得好。是的，说得好。我在试着保护。我在试着保护无辜的人，老兄。你知道为什么吗？因为告密者会挨刀子。好吧。
We're filling a sweatshirt. They also get preferable sentencing usually because they made some sort of an agreement with the prosecution and the government. Which brings us to our guest, Mark Meadows. Which brings us to our guest, who is Sashi? Let's do a Sashi. Which brings us to our guest for today's session, because our guest, he is guilty of entertaining all of us.
我们正在填满一件卫衣。他们通常也会得到较轻的判刑，因为他们与控方和政府达成某种协议。这就把我们带到了我们的嘉宾，马克·梅多斯（Mark Meadows）。这就把我们带到了我们的嘉宾，谁是Sashi？我们来做个Sashi吧。这就把我们带到了我们今天闲聊环节的嘉宾，因为我们的嘉宾，他擅长娱乐我们所有。
That looks criminal over the years. Wait to meet this old outlaw. He's an entertainment outlaw. And he really is. When you see who it is, you're gonna say, yes, he is an entertainment outlaw because he is kind of sometimes outside of the system a little bit.
这些年来，他看起来像个法庭罪犯。真想见见这个老法外狂徒。他是个娱乐界的法外狂徒。他确实是。当你看到他是谁时，你会说，是的，他确实是个娱乐界的法外狂徒，因为他有时有点游离于体制之外。
He does his own thing. He kind of doesn't live here. He kind of lives with his family out in the middle of nowhere sort of, not in the middle of nowhere. Still living at home, huh? He's still living at home with the family, but he doesn't just do the films and all this. He's also the last couple of years,
他走自己的路。他有点不住在这里。他跟家人住在穷乡僻壤的某个地方，也不是穷乡僻壤。还跟家里人住在一起，对吧？他还在跟家人一起住，但他不只拍电影和这些。这几年，
this guy has been busy writing books, and not just books, like New York Times best selling books. And he's got so many films. I can't have him on a game. So many great films that we're not going to talk about. So much. We're not talking about the films, but we can talk about the work and how it gets to work. I know, I know. But we are going to talk about. We're not talking about the films, but we can talk about the work and how it gets to work.
这家伙一直忙着写书，而且不只是写书，比如《纽约时报》畅销书。他拍了那么多电影。我不能让他参加游戏。有那么多伟大的电影，我们不会去谈论。太多了。我们不谈电影，但我们可以谈谈工作以及工作是如何进行的。我知道，我知道。但我们要谈论的是。我们不谈电影，但我们可以谈谈工作以及工作是如何进行的。
I think I know this. But we are going to talk about his books, and we are going to talk about his foundation, and then we are going to talk about his new book, Just Because, which I read, which is four kids that comes out September 12th, 2023. It's Texas's own. I know Matthew McConaughey.
我想我懂这个。但我们要谈论他的书，我们要谈论他的基金会，然后我们要谈论他的新书《Just Because》（就因为），我看过这本书，是为孩子们写的，将于2023年9月12日出版。这是德克萨斯州本土的。我知道马修·麦康纳（Matthew McConaughey）。
I just know. No way. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's back. We finally got him back I have been here before. Yeah, that didn't stay on the show Matthew. Please jump please jump right into your experience the last time Hang on hang on. I'm prepared. I'm prepared for this Matthew. Okay, so Matthew was on Matthew was on hang on with second Oh, no, you're please don't have to play back before we do. Matthew came on the show a couple years ago. Oh, yeah. And he was ready to go. And Jason was having some tech difficulties. Yeah.
我只是知道。不会吧。对，对，对。他回来了。我们终于把他请回来了。我以前来过这里。对，马修，那次没留在节目里。请直接讲讲你上次的经历。等等，等等。我准备好了。我为这个做好了准备，马修。好的，所以马修曾上过，马修曾上过，等等一秒钟。哦，不，你，请不要在我们做这个之前播放回放。马修几年前来过节目。哦，对了。他已经准备好了。而杰森遇到了一些技术故障。对啊。
Oh, yeah, I was saying, did you wait? I must say, did you notice this time pregame? How secure he was about his technical. Tell us about people have a he'll have a shot, a back off, I got you. Listen to where you were. And that's why I said I love that he's having tech problems today. Let's take a listen to where he was last time, guys. Let's roll in. Let's listen. Oh my god.
哦，对，我当时在想，等等！我必须说，你有没有注意到这次在赛前？他对自己的技术是多么自信。告诉我们，人们会有一个，他会有一个机会，退后，我搞定你了。听听你当时在哪里。这就是为什么我说我很高兴他今天遇到了技术故障。让我们听听他上次在哪里，伙计们。让我们切进去。听一听。哦，天哪。
It sounds like he maybe cloned his computer onto another computer and it didn't install the drivers. This one's came our own. It's good time to check that out right before we have a gas. Sean, take your headphones off one more moment please. Thank you for asking me to do that. No, I've been waiting for someone. I'm Matthew.
听起来他可能把他的电脑克隆到了另一台电脑上，而且没有安装驱动程序。这个是我们自己弄的。在我们有嘉宾之前检查一下是个好时机。肖恩，请再把你的耳机拿下一会儿。谢谢你要求我这么做。不，我一直在等某人。我是马修。
Matthew, thanks man. God damn it. You okay till, to go till just before, what is it, eight year time? I don't know, I've got something in one hour and nine, ten minutes. Okay. Let's go right up to that number. You got it. You got it.
马修，谢谢啦。该死。你还可以坚持到什么时候，大概八点之前？我不知道，我有一个小时九分钟、十分钟的时间。好的。我们就进行到那个数字。没问题。没问题。
You got it. Perfect. Thanks, man. Thank you so much. Yeah. Sean, you're good. That's all right. Hello. Hello, hello. Hello, can you hear us?
没问题。太好了。谢谢，伙计。非常感谢。是的。肖恩，你没问题。没关系。喂。喂，喂。喂，能听到我们说话吗？
It's not, I don't see, I don't see it here in the sound thing. So let's cancel. Let's just reschedule this thing. I'm in a total fucking tailspin. Yeah. OK. Sorry, buddy. Sorry, buddy.
我没有，我没看到，我在声音设置里没看到这个。所以取消吧。我们重新安排这件事吧。我整个人彻底他妈的崩溃了。对。好吧。对不起，伙计。对不起，伙计。
Great. Who the fuck is that? Who is that? Yeah. Great. that's helpful. Is that our guest? Yes. Yes. Let me tell you what I've heard here of the last 30 minutes.
太好了。他妈的是谁？那是谁？是的。太好了，这真有帮助。那是我们的嘉宾吗？是的。是的。让我告诉你过去30分钟我在这里听到了什么。
We got a reboot. Oh my god! My parents got cloned and then it got it got Like for the dog peed on so I got to reboot one more time wait a minute buffering wait let me reinstall No, I'm install it's gonna restart. We got failure. I need security. Oh shit. We got a virus You know that start that me fuck that everyone be patient. Oh shit That's a good start, that one. Fuck, that everyone be paid to, oh shit, we're gonna run a telephoto. Peltude, oh, we're gonna get Matthew Mann.
我们需要重启。哦，天哪！我的父母被克隆了，然后它被，它被像狗在上面撒了尿，所以我得再重启一次，等一下，缓冲中，等等，让我重新安装，不，我要安装它，它要重新启动了。我们失败了。我需要安全保障。哦，操。我们中了病毒。你知道那开场，我操，让每个人都有耐心。哦，操，这是一个好的开场，那个。操，让每个人都有耐心，哦，操，我们要开个长焦镜头。Peltude，哦，我们要请到马修·曼了。
That's fantastic. Yeah, yeah, all of that, why are you still out of sandwich in your head? There's not been really entertaining, but not as entertaining as watching fucking Bakeman. Oh, you're not just fucking mentally meditating on this shit.
太棒了。对，对，所有这些，你为什么还在吃三明治？这其实不是很有趣，但没有看他妈的贝克曼更有趣。哦，你不仅仅是在他妈的心里冥想这破事。
You're like, I've got fucking a minute tells, can you just do it? Listen. I'm in the tail spin. I don't know what's going on. Posit, posit, posit, because we can play the whole thing. Okay, so now we're back in. Say when was just glitching, what? What we didn't know is shot none of us knew to bake when we when baby and finally rage quit as we say in the video gaming world he finally rage quit and he was gone and then Matthew rips his camera up and he starts laughing
你就像，我有他妈的分钟倒计时，你能直接开始吗？听着。我整个人崩溃了。我不知道发生了什么。暂停，暂停，暂停，因为我们可以播放整段。好吧，现在我们回来了。说什么时候只是出故障了，什么？我们不知道的是肖恩，我们谁也不知道贝克曼当贝克曼最终愤怒退游（rage quit），正如我们在电子竞技世界里所说的那样，他最终愤怒退游了，他走了，然后马修举起他的摄像头，他开始大笑，
and Sean's going Matthew I didn't know is you and McCunney's got he's written it all down he's as you wrote it all down and I, I'm a part reporter. No, it's baby. He was reading. He was perfect comedy. So all that stuff was, all that stuff was you were doing me with stuff I just said. That was you. That was you.
肖恩说，马修，我不知道是你，麦康纳的家伙，他把这一切都写下来了，他说你把这一切都写下来了，我，我是一个部分记者。不，是贝克曼。他在阅读。他简直是完美的喜剧。所以所有这些东西，所有这些东西都是你在用我刚才说的话捉弄我。那全是你。那全是你。
That was you. That's just mortifying. And you were going on and on. You went so long, I was like, this is, this is funnier. Yeah. And funnier and funnier. And the worst part is me hearing somebody laughing thinking it's Willa Shawnee going, who did that?
那全是你。这简直太丢脸了。而你一直在喋喋不休。你说了那么久，我在想，这，这更有趣。是的。而且越来越有趣。最糟糕的是我听到有人在大笑，以为那是威尔或肖恩在说，谁干的？
That's not helpful. And then I just slammed my laptop shot, took my ball and went home like a bitch. You remember this? Oh, you remember? So it doesn't happen often. It's not one of my prouder moments. My God. I mean, you just come back from golf, some guessing you didn't, you didn't play.
这真没用。然后我直接把笔记本电脑啪地合上，拿上我的球回家了，像个小婊子一样。你还记得这个吗？哦，你还记得？所以这并不经常发生。这不是我最引以为傲的时刻。天哪。我的意思是，你刚打完高尔夫球回来，我猜你没有，你没发挥好。
You didn't play well. No, it's a safe bet. In fact, it had never happened before and it has not happened since. We've had, we've had a couple times where a guest has had a technical glitch and we haven't been able to do it. But we've never had it like in that situation before and that was, it went from being, we felt so bad because you're waiting for so long. And so we felt bad.
你没发挥好。这是一个稳妥的猜测。事实上，这以前从未发生过，自那以后也再没发生过。我们有过几次嘉宾遇到技术故障，我们无法完成录制。但我们从未在那种情况下经历过，那真是，从一开始我们觉得很糟糕，因为你等了那么久。所以我们感到很抱歉。
Then there's a point we can listen to this now too. There was a point where Sean and I start doing sing for real. Do you remember that? We started doing just to entertain ourselves and hopefully you, well, Jason's in a full meltdown. Full melt. And I think, did I, I think, I think maybe you would told me it was a big guess. So don't fuck around kind of thing.
然后有一个时刻，我们现在也可以听这个。有一个时刻，我和肖恩开始现场唱歌。你还记得吗？我们开始唱，只是为了娱乐我们自己，也希望娱乐你，而杰森正在全面崩溃。全面崩溃。我想，我有，我想，也许你曾告诉我这是一个大人物。所以别搞砸了那种。
I just knew I was blowing it, blowing it. Wasn't I, how my daughter's computer or something? Is it not the pre-blummer? Something like that. Yeah. And I'm dumb. Yeah. Well, you were just winging it.
我只知道我搞砸了，搞砸了。我用的是不是我女儿的电脑什么的？不是那个老布鲁默（pre-blummer）吗？诸如此类。是的。我很蠢。是的。好吧，你只是在即兴发挥。
You were on your daughter's computer. I'm dumb and hot. You headed it. It's a great call. You were, you were tardy, dumb and few headed. It's a great call. Oh, you're a, you're a tardy, dominant hot headed. A tardy too. Oh, listen, Matthew, I mean, the fact that you've come back after, though,
你用的是你女儿的电脑。我很蠢又暴躁。你抓住了重点。这是一个极好的评价。你是个，你是个迟钝、愚蠢又暴躁的人。也是个迟钝的人。哦，听着，马修，事实上，在你经历了那场灾难之后，你还能回来，我真是感激不尽。我知道。我的意思是，你是最棒的。谢谢你能来。真是太棒了。你绝对是个带头大哥，能回来，这简直太棒了。我一直在等，我一直在和班尼特（Bennett）、罗布（Rob）、迈克尔·特里（Michael Terry）和所有
absolute wipe out, I can't thank you anymore. I know. I mean, you're the greatest. Thank you for being here. It's so great. You are, you are an absolute kingpin for coming back, which is just the best. And I have been waiting, and I've been talking to Bennett and Rob and Michael Terry and all
那些家伙为这一刻做准备。我们太兴奋了，把音频都准备好了。我们一起寻找高潮时刻，也就是马修宣读所有这些东西的那一段。然后我后来发现那竟然是你。我当时想，我操。事实上，那竟然是你在笑，而我实际上无意中对你大喊大叫，并把笔记本电脑重重地摔在你身上，我当时就想。这真是，这真是太棒了。
those guys preparing for this moment. We were so excited to get the audio queued up. We all went through to find the peak moment, which was Matthew reading out all this stuff. And then I found out afterwards that it was you. And I was, God damn it. And the fact that it was you laughing and that I actually inadvertently yelled at you and slammed the laptop on you, I was just like. It was, it was great.
高质量的娱乐。这真是，但这确实是一场相当艰难的闲聊（sesh）。我得说这真是一场相当艰难的闲聊。这简直是一团糟。所以，所以，所以，马修，正如我在开场白中提到的，这也是其中一件事，就像我说的，你是一个奥斯卡奖得主。我知道，我本来想说插入情节，但管他呢，我们就这么办吧。
High quality entertainment. It was, it was, but it was a pretty tough sassy. I will say it was a pretty tough sassy. It was a mess. So, so, so, Matthew, but I mentioned in the intro and this is one of the things, like I said, you are a, you are an Academy Award-winning actor. I know, I was gonna say insert plot, but fuck it, we'll just do it.
这太酷了，实至名归，这些年来你做了那么多伟大的事情，但真正神奇的是，正如我所提到的，在过去的几年里，你一直在写书。所以你写了《绿灯》（Greenlights），获得巨大成功。现在你写了这本童书，正如我所提到的，我读了这本书，我想我真的认为，
Which is so rad and so well deserved and you've done so much great stuff over the years in, but what's really amazing is in the last couple years, as I mentioned, you have been writing books. So you wrote green lights, huge success. And now you've written this kids book, which as I mentioned the thing that I read, and I thought I really think,
我读过很多童书，因为我基本上，你知道的，我有三个孩子和一个继子，所以是四个孩子。而且这四个孩子智力超群。而且这四个孩子。我读它们纯粹是因为我没有孩子。我花了两个星期才读完。
and I read a lot of kids books, because I have basically, you know, I have three kids in a stepson, so four kids. And a four kids grade intelligence. And a four kids. And I read them just because I don't have kids. It took me two weeks to read it.
但我今天读了它，我读了它，就像我说的，我读过很多童书。我觉得这太棒了，老兄。谢谢。我真的，真的，真的非常喜欢它。我是认真的。你们可能不知道，所以马修写了那本书，好吧，你可以用你自己的话告诉大家这本书的起源是什么。
But I read it today, and I read it, and like I said, I read a lot of kids books. I think it's fantastic, man. Thank you. I really, I really, really enjoyed it. And I mean that. And you guys don't know this, but so Matthew wrote that, well, you can tell them in your own words, what the sort of the Genesis was of this book.
是的。12岁，所以你就像，你就像孩子们一样，对吧？你总是开始考虑如何养育他们，老兄。他们带着各种不同的问题来找你。你会想，哦，天哪。你知道当他们问那些问题时的那一刻，你知道，哦，这是一个棘手的问题。
Yeah. 12, so you're like, you're like kids, right? You start thinking about how to parent them all the time, man. They come on with different questions. You're going, oh geez. You know that moment when they ask those questions, you know that like, oh, this is a doozy.
我最好有一个牛逼的回答，因为我现在的回答将塑造他们看待世界的方式。有时你做好了准备。有时你得去再喝一杯咖啡，你知道吗？不管怎样，我一直在考虑这些事情，所以我有一天晚上做了一个梦，我在2点30分醒来，那是一个，那是一个鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）的小调，老兄。
And I better have a bad ass answer, because what I say right now is going to shape the way they see the world playing on. And sometimes you're up for it. Sometimes you got to go get another cup of coffee, you know? Anyway, I'm always thinking about that stuff, so I have this dream one night and I wake up at 2.30 and it was a, it was a, it was a Bob Dylan diddy, man.
那是：就因为我扔了飞镖，并不意味着它就扎中了，就因为你们有技巧，并不意味着就没有运气，咚，咚，咚，咚，咚。所以我刚刚开始，那个。而且就因为你们有技巧，并不意味着就没有运气，咚咚咚咚咚。所以我刚刚开始，那个核心就是“就因为”，我在2点30分起床，一直把这些对句写到清晨6点30分。
It was just because I threw the dart, does not mean that it stuck and just because you guys skills don't mean there is no luck, doon, doon, doon, doon, doon. And so I just started, the. And just because you guys skills don't mean there is no luck, dood dood dood. And so I just started that hook was just because, and I get up at 2.30 and I jam down all these couplets until 6.30 in the morning.
我大约写了100个对句。哇。然后我回去睡觉了，因为把这些半夜的灵感，那些凌晨2点30分的灵感沉淀一下是很好的，看看它们是否经得起推敲。对吧。所以我第二天早上10点起床，我想，哦，这挺酷的。
I got about 100 couplets. Wow. I then go back to bed because it's nice to sleep on some of those midnight, those 2.30 in the morning inspirations to see if they still hold. Right. So I get up at 10 o'clock next morning, I was like, oh, this is pretty groovy.
这可能会很有趣。这是一首不错、有趣的小调。当我浏览它时，我想，你知道吗？这里有大约25个对句很适合小孩子们，是关于我一直试图和我的孩子们谈论的事情。他们带着问题来找我。所以我把这些组合在一起，发给了我的图书经纪人。
This could be fun. It's a nice, fun, did he song? And as I looked through it, I was like, you know what? There's pieces in here that's about 25 compasses that be good for kiddos that are like about things that I've been trying to talk to my kids about. Questions they've been coming to me with. And so I put those together, sent them to my book agent.
他说，这会是一本很好的童书。你应该分享它。这就是《Just Because》的由来。太酷了。太酷了。你的孩子多大？10岁，13岁，15岁，10岁，13岁，14岁。对。所以他们现在面临着一套不同的问题，他们甚至可能不会承认自己需要答案。是的，完全是另一套。但它棒就棒在，它确实是，它真正突出了生活中的矛盾，对吧？我喜欢这一点。对于一个孩子来说，这就是为什么我这么喜欢它。
He goes, this would be a great kid's book. You should share it. And that's what just because. That's so cool. That's so cool. How old are your kids? 10, 13, 15, 10, 13, 14. Right. So they're coming into a different set of questions now that they might not even admit they need answers to. And yeah, it's a whole different set. But what's great about it is, it is kind of, it really highlights the contradictions in life, right? And I love that. And for a kid, this is why I love so much.
他刚才说了，但它开头是这样的：就因为他们扔了飞镖，并不意味着它就扎中了；就因为他们有技巧，并不意味着就没有运气；就因为他们让你失望了，并不意味着你必须情绪低落；就因为他们笨手笨脚，并不意味着他们没有节奏感。这全都是这些内容，还有插画，你的插画师，是谁来着？雷内·卡里拉（René Carillo）。非常棒的插画。真的很有助于你讲述这个故事，
He just said it, but it starts off with just because they throw the dart, they threw the dart doesn't mean that it's stuck just because they got skills, doesn't mean there is no luck. Just because they let you down, doesn't mean you got to get low, just because they're clumsy, doesn't mean they have no flow. And it's just all this stuff and the illustration too, your illustrator whom. René Carilla. Really great illustrations. Like really helps you tell this story
以这种非常酷的方式。我认为作为一个孩子，这里有那么多伟大的教训。有一个地方，就像那个孩子，它讲到，我要找到这个，因为这是我最喜欢的一个我深爱的地方。里面有一个非常棒的寓意。就因为我撒了谎，并不意味着我就是个骗子。然后你会看到大哥哥，
in this really cool way. And I think as a kid, there's so many great lessons. There's one where like the kid, it talks about, I'm gonna find this one, because this is one of my favorites that I love. There was such a sort of great message. Just because I lied doesn't mean that I'm a liar. And it's up, you see this older brother,
小女孩把棒球打碎了窗户。接下来，大哥哥把责任揽了下来，保护小妹妹。这就好比“就因为我撒了谎，并不意味着我就是个骗子”。这其实是个很酷的教训。对。有时候说个善意的谎言是个好时机，你知道我的意思吗？另一件与之相关的事是，
the little girls hit the baseball through a window. And the next thing, the older brother is taking the blame for it, protecting the little sister. And it's just because I lie doesn't mean that I'm a liar. And it's kind of a cool lesson. Yeah. Sometimes good time to take a white lie, you know what I mean? And the other thing that came from is,
你知道，别人做了某事。你告诉我，威尔，你现在对我撒谎，然后我说，老兄，你以后是个骗子。而你说，哦，老兄，不，我只是想逃避这个。抱歉，我是康纳·海（con of hey），巴拉巴拉。你并没有继续对我撒谎。我把一整个标签贴在你的性格上是错误的，但把一个人称为骗子，与说“老兄，你对我撒谎了”是截然不同的。
and you know, somebody does something. You tell me, Will, you tell me a lie right now, and I go, man, you're after a liar. And you go, oh man, no, I was trying to get away with this. Sorry, I'm a con of hey, blah, blah. And you don't continue to lie to me. I was wrong in casting the whole blanket over your character, but it's very different to call someone a liar
因为当你称呼某人，尤其是小孩子们，老兄，你称呼某人或成年人，你叫他们骗子或者别的什么。你用一个词把他们概括了，其实并不是骗子。他们会防御的，老兄。他们只会用言语反击。你会说，嘿，老兄，你在质疑我的品格。
than to go, man, you lied to me. Because you call someone, especially kiddos, man, you call someone or adults, so you call them a liar or whatever. You blanket them with anything in a proper, not a liar. They get defensive, bro. They're just gonna fight in words. You go, hey, man, you're casted on my character.
你说，嘿，老兄，我不喜欢你对我的那种特定行为。你对我有错。你别再对我撒谎了。是的。好吧。是的。那是另一回事。
You say, hey, man, I don't like that specific time you did to me. You did me wrong. You don't lie to me again. Yeah. All right. Yeah. That's a different thing.
我们可以在这一点上达成共识并修复关系。你可以说，我很抱歉，我可以接受你的道歉。我们继续前进。是的。现在，如果有人一次又一次地对你胡扯和撒谎，那么你就会想，一次耻辱于你，两次耻辱于我，因为你确实是个骗子。那是一种性格特征。
We can come together on that and repair. You can go, I'm sorry, I can go accept your project. We move on. Yeah. Now, if someone continues to bullshit and lie to you over and over, then you go, well, once shame on you, twice shame on me, because you are a liar. That's a character trait.
但通常我们用一个词给某人贴上标签，用一个名词，你是个骗子。那个人是个骗子。他们必须戴上那个红字。对于这一切，你是怎么看的？你是不是像我这样的人，如果有人对你做了那种事，我会直言不讳地指出来。
But usually we blanket somebody with a, with a terminality, with a term, a me because you are a liar. That's a character trait. But usually we blanket somebody with a terminal, with a term, a noun, you're a liar. That person's a liar. They gotta wear that scarlet letter. Where do you sit with all this, are you someone like myself, like if somebody does something like that to me, I will call them on it.
但一旦他们道歉，我就会原谅。我可能不会忘记，但不会记恨。但我会信任一个人，直到他们给我不信任的理由。但还有其他人，是的，请说。我里面有几个关于“就因为我原谅了你，并不意味着我仍然信任”的句子。对，对，对。
But as soon as they apologize, I will forgive. I probably won't forget, but not at a grudge level. But like I'll trust someone till they give me a reason not to. But there are other people, yeah, go ahead. I got a couple of it in there about just because I forgive you does not mean that I still trust. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
这是真的。我必须重新建立信任。我也是带着信任开始的。我一开始的信任度非常高。有些人会说，你的信任度太高了。但听着，如果有人走过来说，嘿，老兄，对不起，我搞砸了，我的错。而且我真诚地相信，我喜欢说：
And that's true. I gotta be rebuilt. I go in trust first, too. I go in with a very high trust level early. Some people go, you're going in with too high of a trust level. But look, if someone comes and is able to say, Hey, man, sorry, I bogged my bad. And I sincerely believe, I love going.
宽恕不仅对那个人大有裨益。对于施予宽恕的我们来说，这也是一种赦免。对吧。你知道，我里面有一句说，就因为，是什么来着，就因为我放手了，并不意味着我停止了攀登。对吧。有人问，有孩子问过我关于这个的问题。
Forgiveness is not only great for that person. It's amnesty for us who's doing the forgiven. Right. You know, I got a couple that in here that says just because, what is it, just because I let go does not mean that I quit climbing. Right. Someone asked, kid, ask me about that.
我说，嗯，这有点像宽恕。放手就是宽恕，对吧？对，对，对。这是否意味着你没有在进化？这是否意味着你没有在上升？不，大多数时候这意味着你正在上升。你在成熟。其中有一个很棒的插图，
And I was like, well, that's kind of like forgiveness. Letting go is forgiven, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And does that mean you're not evolving? Does that mean you're not ascending? No, most of the times that mean you are ascending. You are maturing. That the great illustration with that,
如果我没记错的话，是一个女孩在玩滑板。她放手了，冲下去。然后在下一张图里，她开始在路上往上爬。对。你生命中有这样的人吗，我的意思是，大家会知道我为什么这么问。
if I remember correctly, is it's a girl on a skateboard. She lets go, goes down. And then in the next picture, she's kind of rising up on the road. Yeah. It's cool. Are there people in your life that you, I mean, the guys will know why I'm asking this.
你生命中是否还有人，你仍然很难原谅他们？你知道的，因为，是的，我知道。你猜第一个人是谁？我不知道。哦，你自己？不。哦。
Are there people in your life that you still have a hard time forgiving? You know, because, yeah, I know. You guess who the first person is? I don't know. Oh, yourself? No. Oh.
这本书很大一部分讲的就是这个，老兄。所有这些我们谈论对别人做的事情。老兄，我们必须包括这一点，即：嘿，你自己呢？我们必须有适当的精神宽容。好吧，是的，我的意思是，作家写的是作家所了解的，对吧？我的意思是，所有这些东西都源于你。你有这些想法，你有这些感受，然后把它用文字表达了出来。
That's a lot of what this book's about, man. A lot of all these things that we talk about doing to others. Man, we got to include going, hey, how about yourself? We got to have the proper mental leniency. Well, yeah, I mean, our writer writes what a writer knows, right? I mean, so all this stuff came from you. You had these thoughts, you had these feelings and that brought it out in words.
太酷了。现在，听一段我们的赞助商广告。本期《SmartLess》由 Framebridge 部分赞助播出，这是一种简单且经济实惠的方式，可以为几乎任何东西定制装裱，我们也这么做了。Framebridge 精选了一系列画框风格和设计专家，让为你的作品选择完美的画框变得有趣而简单。整个过程非常简单。
Yeah. That's so cool. And now, a word from our sponsor. This episode of SmartList is brought to you in part by Framebridge, the easy and affordable way to custom frame just about anything, and we have. Frambridge has a curated selection of frame styles and design experts to make it fun and easy to choose the perfect frame for your piece. The process is really simple.
在 frambridge.com 上在线订购，要么上传数码照片让他们打印并装裱，要么把你的艺术品寄过来，他们会寄给你一个免费的安全预付包装。然后 Framebridge 会使用最高质量的材料定制装裱你的作品，并免费运送到你的门口。这不是很酷吗？简直是一条龙服务。能收到的最好的礼物莫过于一个带着照片的相框。
Order online at frambridge.com, either upload a digital photo for them to print and frame, or mail your art in, they'll send you a free secured prepaid packaging. And then frame bridge, custom frames, your piece using the highest quality materials and ships it to your door for free. Isn't that cool? It's like all the way. The best gift to ever get is a frame with a photo in it.
这样你就不必做任何繁重的工作了。这也是我喜欢做的事。我订购了一个奥尔托（alto）画框，把它作为百老汇某人的闭幕之夜礼物送了出去。然后我实际上还订购了黑胡桃木画框，现在它放在我洛杉矶的办公室里，里面是我和斯科蒂在纽约时剧院外的合影。
So you don't have to do any of the work. And that's what I like to do. I ordered an alto frame and I gave it to as a gift, a closing night gift to somebody on Broadway. And then I actually ordered also the black walnut frame, which is now in my office in Los Angeles, but it's a picture of me in Scotty outside the theater when we were in New York.
它们太漂亮了。它们与任何家具都能完美融合，简直美极了。真的非常非常酷。Framebridge 的定价公平透明。定价完全根据你作品的尺寸而定，你可以提前确切知道你要支付的费用。现在他们在纽约市、波士顿、费城、华盛顿特区、马里兰州、弗吉尼亚州、
They're beautiful. They blend in with any furniture, they're gorgeous. It's really, really cool. Framebridge pricing is fair and transparent. Pricing is based simply upon the size of your piece and you know exactly what you'll pay up front. And now they have 19 retail stores in New York City, Boston, Philadelphia, DC, Maryland, Virginia,
芝加哥和亚特兰大拥有19家零售店。因此，你可以获得一对一的专家设计建议并亲自查看系列产品。访问 frameridge.com 或当地的 Framebridge 商店即可开始为几乎任何东西定制装裱。SmartLess 由 ADT 赞助。现在 ADT 专业安装 Google Nest 产品，让您的家既安全又智能。
and Chicago, and Atlanta. So you can get one-to-one expert design advice and see the collection in person. Visit frameridge.com or a local frameridge store to get started and custom frame just about anything. thing. SmartList is sponsored by ADT. Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products, so your home is safe and smart.
您可以随时随地查看您的家并管理您的安全系统。通过 Nest 摄像头和 Nest 门铃，您甚至可以获得智能警报，以便收到对您最重要的通知。Google Nest 摄像头可以区分人、动物、车辆，或者通过 Nest 门铃甚至可以识别包裹。
You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cams and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you receive notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cams can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest Doorbell, even a package.
这不是很酷吗？作为每月 ADT 服务的一部分，通过 Nest Aware，您可以获得 30 天的事件视频历史记录，甚至还有更智能的通知，例如看到熟悉或不熟悉的面孔时。此外，在分秒必争的关键时刻，您可以信赖 ADT 24/7 的专业监控。您可以查看警报事件的视频，并通过轻触屏幕来验证或取消
Isn't that cool? And with Nest Aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event, video history, and even smarter notifications, like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel
警报。当家居安全中最值得信赖的名字融入 Google 的智能技术时，您的家就会变得高枕无忧。立即访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-ASAP。Google Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。Google Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。感谢 Viori 服饰对本节目的支持。
an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google Nest Cam Nestor Bell and Nest Aware trademarks of Google LLC. Google Nest Cam Nestorbel and Nest Aware trademarks of Google LLC. Thanks to Viori clothing for supporting the show.
Viori 生产高端功能性服饰，其灵感源自积极的加州海岸生活方式，融合了健身、冲浪、运动和艺术。所有产品都专为运动设计，但看起来和穿起来都不像运动服。正如大家所知，我们一直是 Viori 的长期粉丝。所以我们很高兴向大家介绍他们最新的产品之一，男士核心慢跑裤（Men's Core Jogger）。它具备你对核心短裤（Core Short）的所有喜爱，
Viori makes premium performance-apparel inspired by the active coastal California lifestyle and integration of fitness, surf, sport, and art. Everything is designed to work out in, but doesn't look or feel like it. We've been fans of Vury for a long time, as you guys well know. So we're excited to tell you about one of their newest products, the Men's Core Jogger. It's everything you love about the Core Short,
同样的吸湿排汗弹力编织面料和内部平角短裤内衬，带来极致的随时随地舒适感，现在推出了慢跑裤款式。我必须告诉你们，我从 Viori 买了一条新慢跑裤，去了健身房，现在我从百老汇演完回到洛杉矶，重新开始了我的日常生活。现在我又回到了两项运动并去健身房的节奏。
the same moisture wicking stretch woven fabric and interior boxer brief liner for the ultimate and go anywhere comfort, now in a jogger. I have to tell you, I got a new jogger from Vury, went to the gym, now I'm back in my routine right now, I'm back in Los Angeles from doing Broadway. Now I'm back in my two and going to the gym.
我穿着慢跑裤去健身房锻炼，然后回了家。大约有15分钟的时间，所以我没有洗澡或做别的，就要出门吃晚饭，我把裤子留着没换。穿着慢跑裤就去吃晚饭了。没有人投以异样的眼光。你猜桌上谁最舒服？我。Viori 是对你幸福感的一项投资。
I wore my jogger pants to the gym to work out and came home. Had like 15 minutes, so I didn't shower anything, to go out to dinner, left them on. Left the joggers on, went out to dinner. No judgment from anybody. And guess who's the most comfortable at the table? Me. Viori is an investment in your happiness.
对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买享 8 折的优惠，在 Viori.com/smartless 上为自己购置一些地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装吧。网址是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartless。你不仅可以享受首次购买 8 折优惠，而且美国境内订单满 75 美元即可享受免费配送和免费退货。访问 Viori.com/smartless，探索 Viori 服饰的多功能性。
For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase, get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash Smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing.
现在回到节目中。是的，我一直在想你刚才说的话，关于给某人贴上标签，他们对你撒谎，然后把他们定性为骗子。对我来说，这有点落入这样的范畴：当人们说，“你知道，我是那种总是……”时，我总是说，等一下。在任何特定的一天里，我们所有人都是那种什么都能做的人。你不能独占那种模式。
And now back to the show. Yeah, I was thinking about what you were saying about casting someone with, they lie to you and then casting him as a liar. And kind of for me, it falls in the same category as when people say, you know, I'm the kind of person who, I always say, hang on a second. We're all the kind of person who anything on any given day. You don't get to just own that lane.
在那一天，你做了那个。但在接下来的那一天，你可能会做这个。所以我有点排斥这种说法。我认为我们都有能力犯错，我们都有能力获得救赎，我们都有能力做很多事情，你不觉得吗？是的，我这么认为。而且看，而且看，那些借口和语境，你知道的，这有点像那样。
On this day, you did that. But on the next day, you might do this. And so I kind of reject that a little bit. And I think that we are all capable of making mistakes, and we're all capable of redemption, and we're all capable of a lot of things, don't you? Yeah, I do. And look, and look, those pretext context, you know, it's a little bit like that.
好吧，现在我很诚实。你会想，哦，操，你当时在撒谎吗？对。对，对，对，对。你用这些来作前置铺垫：就像，别，我不需要这种假设。别给我下套。我懂。我和你在同一水平线上，老兄。
Okay, well, now I'm being honest. You're like, oh shit, were you lying there at the time? Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You pretext these things with, it was like, don't, I don't need the supposition. Don't set me up. I get it. I'm on par with you, man.
开诚布公地来。你知道的，我们，我们，我们，我们坦诚相待。坦白说，是的，我们都知道宝贝们就在中间，这就是矛盾所在。是的，你今天可能会打出柏忌（bogey）。你明天可能会抓下小鸟球（birdie）。你可能会做到。今天做得很好，然后明天把它搞砸。所以我们带着这种平淡的态度来。更容易接受这种前置铺垫：现在让我铺垫一下，我想
Come in straight. You know, let's, let's, let's, let's be straight. Frank speaking, yes and no, we all know the babies are in the middle and it's contradiction. And yeah, you may bogey today. You may birdie tomorrow. You may do it. Do it. Do it well today, and then eff it up tomorrow. So we come in on that flat line. It's a little bit easier to get along with that, the pretext of, now let me set this up, what I'm trying
表达的意思。好吧，你知道，我一直，我记得那天晚上我们从晚宴往回走，大约五年前在法国南部，一个颁奖活动上，你对我说，你问我，安东（Art），我们其实不认识彼此，她说，安东，我们有很多共同的朋友，他们说你和我应该成为朋友。
to say. Well, you know, I've always, you know, I remember we were walking back from dinner that night, about five years ago in South of France, a wordies thing, and you said to me, you go, aren't it? We don't know each other, it goes, aren't it? We got a lot of friends in common who say that you and I should be friends.
我当时就想：走吧。我当时就想：走吧。我太喜欢你这一点了。你在你的，我喜欢你的自信。我喜欢，每次我听你说话，你都有一种，我不知道，有一种类似智慧的东西，但我又不想让它听起来太老套。你有一种特质，你谈论你的感受的方式
I was like, let's go. I was like, let's go. And I love that about you. And you're in your so, I love your confidence. And I love, every time I hear you speak, you've got, I don't know, there's like this kind of like, I wanna say wisdom, but I don't want it to sound too hokey. You've got this thing about, you talk about how you feel
当时我就想，走吧。我当时就想，走吧。我真的很喜欢你这一点。你正处于，我很喜欢你的自信。而且每次听到你说话，我都觉得，怎么说呢，有种类似于，我想说是智慧，但我又不想听起来太假。你有一种特质，你谈到你是如何感受的
in a way that I find is very disarming, and I love it, it's a superpower. I think it's talking about the way you, and be vulnerable. Yes, on Instagram, I'll watch your stuff, and I'm like, you're like, you, I mean, you're like, you know, an Oprah type of like, you know, you have this gift. But it's a vulnerability, I think, and I think, right, I think that that, don't you think so, Sean?
以一种我觉得非常卸下防备的方式，我喜欢这样，这是超能力。我觉得这是在说你那种方式，而且还能展现脆弱。对，在Instagram上，我会看你的内容，然后我觉得，你就好像，你，我的意思，你就好像，你知道的，奥普拉那种类型的人，你知道的，你身上有这种天赋。但这也是一种脆弱，我觉得，而且我觉得，对吧，我觉得那个，你不觉得吗，肖恩？
I mean, I don't know. Yeah, yeah, for sure, for sure, vulnerability, but when we talk about that a lot too, but just like, what you said, well, to Matthew about your wisdom is like, where do you get, how, what happened in your life that gave you this kind of self-awareness enough to look inside yourself and share then be able to communicate
我的意思，我不知道。对啊，对啊，确实，确实，脆弱，但我们也很常讨论这个，不过就像你刚才说的，对马修说的关于你的智慧，就像是，你是在哪里得到的，怎么说呢，你生活里发生了什么，才让你有了这种自我意识，能够去审视自己的内心，然后去分享，并且能够去交流
and have the tools to communicate to other people, your philosophies and life values and all those things, which I just absorb. Oh, I don't know. It's a good question, man. Thank you. Thank you. Let me give you one of many answers here. I don't know. It's a good question, man. I mean, thank you. I will let me give you one of one of many answers here and I wrote this the other day. And this may be a bit of when you're talking to a way to talk about vulnerability in a fun way. And I wrote this as they're like, we are all brilliant dramatic actors when we realize we're in a comedy.
并且拥有与其他人交流的工具，你的哲学、生活价值观以及所有这些，而我都只是在吸收。哦，我不知道。这真是个好问题，老兄。谢谢。谢谢。我来给你讲讲这里的众多答案之一吧。我不知道。这真是个好问题，老兄。我是说，谢谢。我，我来给你讲讲这里的众多答案之一吧，我前几天刚写了这个。当你谈论以一种有趣的方式谈论脆弱时，这可能有点像。我写下的是，当意识到我们身处喜剧时，我们所有人都是出色的戏剧演员。
Yeah. Yeah. The comedy, it allows us, we've talked, allows you to forgive, allows you to be an ass, allows you to go over the top. It says, oh, but wait too far that time. Come on back, got a second chance. It allows you to go, this is not so precious.
对。对。喜剧，它允许我们，我们聊过，允许你原谅，允许你犯浑，允许你表现得夸张过火。它会说，哦，不过那次做得有点过头了。回来吧，再给你一次机会。它会说，这没那么珍贵。
It allows you to not go, well, you know, I want to tell you, sometimes I do this, like you were saying, well, it's like, man, we're in it. We're in it. We did it. Come on, man. Okay, Bog, you screwed up. Now try it again.
它能让你不再去想，嗯，你知道的，我想告诉你，有时候我就是这么干的，就像你刚才说的，嗯，这就好比，老兄，我们身在其中。我们在局中。我们做到了。来吧，老兄。好吧，博格，你搞砸了。现在再试一次。
It, the comedy of life allows me, I think for, for certain truths to hear them or pick something out that someone says, I love, I love listening to people. I've traveled. I love that too. And I pick out things that people say. To the extent you feel comfortable talking about it,
它，生活的喜剧允许我，我觉得对于某些真理来说，能够听到它们，或者从别人说的话里挑出一些东西，我喜欢，我喜欢听别人说话。我旅行过。我也很喜欢那样。我挑出别人说的话。在你觉得舒服的范围内谈论它，
what was childhood like, what was like upbringing? Like, did you think all of these, this time in your life where you are sharing all of these great thoughts and ideas now have come to fruition because of stuff that happened to you as a childhood or you were raised in a certain way or. I mean, I don't know. I mean, look, I've always been an existential dude.
童年是什么样的，成长经历是什么样的？就像，你觉得你现在分享所有这些美妙思想和观点的这段人生时期，之所以能修成正果，是因为你童年发生的事情，还是因为你是在某种特定方式下被抚养长大的，或者。我的意思，我不知道。我的意思，你看，我一直都是个存在主义的家伙。
I'm always been intrigued with, oh, if I can just get a little closer to figuring out the riddle. The big riddle. What are we doing here? Is there a God what's happening? What really matters? What doesn't? That entertains me. You find a way in which to steer a lot of your performances, a lot of your characters, into places of really solid grounding kind of foundations. There's a deep humanity to all the characters you play. And some you can tell is not on the page,
我一直对……哦，如果我能更接近于解开这个谜题就好了。那个巨大的谜题。我们在这是在干嘛？有上帝吗，发生了什么？什么才是真正重要的？什么不重要？这让我觉得很有意思。你找到了一种方式，把你的很多表演、你的很多角色，引导到非常扎实的根基、某种基础上去。你扮演的所有角色都有一种深厚的人性。而且有些地方你能看出剧本里是没有的，
but you find that place in you and you share that through the character and then to the audience. And it's always goes down easy. I don't think you ever ask the audience to buy something that you're selling that is inauthentic. I appreciate that.
但你找到了自己身上那个地方，并通过角色把它分享给观众。而且这总是很容易被接受。我想你从来不会要求观众去买你推销的那些虚假不真实的东西。我很感激。
Thank you. Yeah, for sure. You know how that is, we don't, we don't want to be watching performance having to do the math. Yeah, we all love to be manipulated. We just don't like to be confused. Yeah, but you find a place to keep it inside your scope, your boundaries, your person.
谢谢。对，确实。你知道那是怎样的，我们不，我们不想看一场还要去动脑筋算计的表演。对，我们都喜欢被操纵。我们只是不喜欢被搞糊涂。对，但你找到一个地方把它保持在你的视野、你的边界、你的人格之内。
And to build on Sean's question, like do you think that's always been there? Was it something? I'm sure as we get older and wiser, it gets better and better, our ability to be human, but like, one of your parents kind of like that. Yeah, that's what I was going to say. Did somebody model that for you? Look, I come from a family of hams. That's her damn sure. I'm probably third and out of five, my two brothers, mom and dad, third, and I would be a bronze medal winner as far as when it comes to wanting and willingness and performing.
顺着肖恩的问题继续说，比如你觉得这种特质一直都在吗？是某种东西吗？我确信随着我们年龄增长、阅历增加，这种能力会越来越好，我们展现人性的能力，但是，你的父母中有人是这样的吗？对，我正要这么说。有人为你树立了这样的榜样吗？听着，我来自一个爱演的家庭。那绝对是千真万确的。我在五个孩子里大概排老三，我的两个兄弟，还有爸妈，老三，如果论想要、愿意以及表现自己的话，我能拿个铜牌。
Yeah, really? Yeah, I mean, dad was maybe fourth now that I'm talking about. Dad was an absolute host of a ham. My mom was always talk about existential logic. You know, she, I got her story in the book of Green Life Tom was always talk about existential logic, you know. She, I got her story in the book of Green Life where she told me to sign my name
真的吗？对，我是说，现在说起来，我爸大概排老四。我爸绝对是个极度爱现的主持人。我妈总是谈论存在主义逻辑。你知道的，她，我在《绿灯》那本书里写过她的故事，汤姆总是谈论存在主义逻辑，你知道的。她，我在《绿灯》里写了她的故事，当时她让我把名字签在
under this anashford poem. And I said, but I didn't write it, she was, but you understand it. And it means something to you. I said, yeah, she goes within the shares. Ah, I signed my name under it and I won the seventh grade poach contest. Early AI.
这首安·阿施福德的诗下面。我说，但我没写过这个，她说，但你懂它。它对你有意义。我说，对，她说：那就把它署上你的名。啊，我把名字签在下面，然后我赢得了七年级诗歌比赛。早期的AI。
Early AI plagiarism. But I mean, so she was always like no TV. Why mom? Because I'm not going to let you sit in here and watch somebody do something. You can go out and find out if you can do it yourself. It was like, bam, okay. So you were just pushed on to say to be the subject that I will say. And inadvertently or indirectly
早期的AI抄袭。但我的意思是，所以她总是这样：不看电视。为什么妈妈？因为我才不让你坐在这儿看别人做什么。你可以出去看看你自己能不能做到。这就好像，砰，好吧。所以你只是被逼着去成为我所说的主题。而且无意中或间接地
was set me up for doing what I do, is you were always forced to be the subject. Go find out, go find out. It's live, you get one take, go. Don't ask, don't watch, do it. Come back with a scar, let me know. Yeah, I love that. And then the comedy side of that is,
为我做我现在的事做好了准备，就是你总是被迫成为那个主体。去找出答案，去找出答案。这是直播，你只有一次机会，上。不要问，不要看，去做。带着伤疤回来，让我知道。对，我喜欢这样。然后其中的喜剧成分是，
what tickles my family. Bruce is a lot of people. We were like, we were comedy quick. So there was no risk of embarrassment or shame or making a clown of yourself. It was, you got to pull your pants down to get their attention, right? You got to, and if you came in on any kind of high horse or a little arrogant or a little thought you were the shit, my family just penetrated you to the ground
让我家人觉得好笑的事。布鲁斯很多人也是。我们属于那种，喜剧反应极快的人。所以根本不用担心尴尬、出丑或者把自己当成小丑。那是，你得脱下裤子才能吸引他们的注意力，对吧？你得，如果你带着任何高高在上的姿态，或者有点傲慢，或者觉得老子天下第一，我的家庭就会直接把你打击得体无完肤
until you cried Uncle and as soon as you cried Uncle, they'd all lift you up and throw you in the air, man. Yeah! You'd be like, what's your favorite drink? What's your favorite meal? Let's cook it for you. Yeah, same. That was like a test.
直到你认输求饶，而你一旦认输求饶，他们就会把你高高举起，扔向空中，老兄！对！你会像这样：你最喜欢的饮料是什么？你最喜欢的饭菜是什么？我们给你做。对，一样。那就好像是一场测试。
I remember I have three older brothers. They would treat me, I remember one time they pinned me down and forced me to shave, because I was just like a 12 or 13 years old, I was just getting a little peach fuzz on my upper lip. And they're like, we're gonna teach you how to shave. What?
我记得我有三个哥哥。他们会这样对付我，我记得有一次他们把我按倒在地，强行给我刮胡子，因为我当时就像个12、13岁的孩子，上唇刚刚长出一点细软的绒毛。他们就说：我们要教你刮胡子。什么？
And they pinned me down in the family room and got a razor and they just covered me and they shaved my face. Yes. So bizarre. That's cute. Right to passage, initiations, So bizarre. That's cute. Right to passage, initiations, you know.
他们把我按在家庭活动室里，拿了一把剃须刀，直接抹满泡沫，然后把我的脸刮了。没错。太诡异了。真可爱。成年礼、加入仪式，太诡异了。真可爱。成年礼、加入仪式，你知道的。
Yeah, crazy. But now let me ask you because, you know, I don't know if you ever felt this way to be the second you were on your rise to becoming Matthew McConaughey as we know him. And this big massive global superstar was there ever a moment because you're so outgoing and you're so willing to share every thought and feeling now, which is great? Was there ever a moment where you didn't? And when you didn't, what was the switch that made you go?
对，太疯狂了。但现在让我问你，因为，你知道的，我不知道你是否曾有过这种感觉，就在你正要崛起成为我们所熟知的马修·麦康纳的那段时期。而那个庞大的全球超级巨星，有没有那么一个时刻——因为你现在这么外向，这么愿意分享每一个想法和感受，这很棒——有没有那么一个时刻你没有这么做？而当你没有这么做的时候，是什么样的转变让你觉得：
You know what, fuck it. I'm not gonna be mysterious anymore. I'm not gonna do this anymore. I'm gonna just share everything who I am. Sure. Look, I mean, I'm still measured about what I share. I just have my mind's quicker to notice as it's coming out of my mouth.
你知道吗，去他的。我再也不要保持神秘了。我再也不要这么做了。我要把我是谁的一切都分享出来。当然。听着，我的意思是，对于我分享的内容，我依然是有分寸的。我只是脑子转得更快了，能在话刚出口时就注意到。
Do I do, who, I could say that right now that I know would be a bold print. And as it's coming out of my mouth, I can catch myself and go, whistling, let me tell you that, hair. Now that took years of getting there. Did I notice, do I also notice that there is real value in demand for celebrities, movie stars, to not be around until that Friday
我有没有，谁，我刚才如果说出那句话，我知道那会成为粗体印刷。而且在话出口的瞬间，我能抓住自己并心想：慢着，让我别说那个，伙计。现在，这需要花好几年时间才能做到。我有没有注意到，我也注意到，对于名人、电影明星来说，保持神龙见首不见尾直到周五
night when your movie comes out. Yes. Is there value to having two tinted blacks of urban when you leave in the pop roti file because they don't know which one you're in and you sneak in the back and you're not seen. Yes, is there value to wearing the same thing out every single day so every pop roti shot looks like it was the same day so they lose that?
你电影上映的那天晚上，这里面真的有价值吗？有的。当你坐着两辆贴着深色车膜的轿车离开帕帕拉齐的照片库时，因为他们不知道你究竟在哪一辆车里，然后你从后门溜进去没有被发现，这有价值吗？有的。每天出门都穿同一套衣服，这样每一张狗仔队照片看起来都像是在同一天拍的，从而让他们失去这种爆料价值，这有价值吗？
Yes, is it value to go, where is he? I don't know where they are. I can only go spend time with them when they come out in the movie in the theater. Yes. I just tried that for a little bit. Very short in my time. I was like, Bullshit, this is how much work.
是的，这有价值吗：他在哪儿？我不知道他们在哪里。我只有在他们出来拍电影、进剧场时才能去和他们相处。是的。我只是尝试了一小段时间。在我的经历里非常短暂。我觉得：扯淡，这得费多大劲啊。
Yeah, that's what I was gonna say. It sounds exhausting. I started to notice, especially when I had kids, I was like, man, I started to notice if you're gonna live by that code that I just brought up, you start to let your fame wag your life. Meaning, I always said, that's what just keep living to back. What are we doing? You start to let your fame wag your life, meaning, I always said, that's what just keep living to back.
对，我正要这么说。听起来精疲力竭。我开始注意到，特别是当我有了孩子之后，我想，老兄，我开始注意到，如果你要按照我刚才提到的那种准则生活，你就会开始让你的名气来左右你的生活。意思就是，我总是说，那就是继续生活。我们在干什么？你开始让你的名气来左右你的生活，意思就是，我总是说，那就是继续生活。
What are we doing? I got rights as a citizen, a mammal, before I have rights or rights taken away from me as any kind of celebrity. So, for instance, we're in New York, my son's four years old, fire truck, the girl who's doing my makeups husband doing is run to a, she's a fire chief at the fire department.
我们在干什么？作为公民、作为哺乳动物，在我的任何名誉权利被剥夺之前，我首先拥有权利。所以，举个例子，我们在纽约，我儿子四岁，消防车，帮我化妆的那位女士的丈夫跑去……她消防局的消防队长。
She goes, hey, my son says, I'd love to see a fire truck. She goes, oh, let me call my husband, I'll swing by. He swings by the Greenwich Hotel, right there. I mean, essential. This is when the pop rods are all around. Pools up front, my son's like, I gotta wanna go see the fire truck. Well, I know if I go down there.
她说，嘿，我儿子说，我很想看看消防车。她说，哦，我给我丈夫打个电话，我顺便开过来。他把车开到了格林威治酒店，就在那儿。我的意思是，太关键了。这是狗仔队四处盘踞的时候。停在前门，我儿子就说：我想去看看消防车。好吧，我知道如果我走下去的话。
It's gonna be a pop paparazzi big shoot it. But I'm also like, my son was to see his first fire truck. Right. That's gotta take precedent, right? If I tell him, no, not right now, I feel like a heel. I feel like a coward. I feel like a whooist. What am I doing?
那会是一场狗仔队的大型拍摄。但我也在想，我儿子想看他的第一辆消防车。对。那必须得放在首位，对吧？如果我告诉他：不，现在不行，我会觉得自己像个混蛋。我觉得自己像个懦夫。我觉得自己像个胆小鬼。我到底在干什么？
I gotta go down and get rid of it. You gotta see the fire truck. Later on, I had to explain why I was everyone watching and why I was at the big deal. But you got to see the fire truck. I've chose I had to explain why I was everyone watching and why I was at the big deal, but you got to see the fire truck. I've chose to say, let me go on with my life. Let me make choices that made me, by life first, before I'm gonna curtail those
我得下去把这事儿办了。你得去看看消防车。后来，我不得不解释为什么每个人都在围观，以及为什么这是件大事。但你得去看消防车。我选择说：让我继续我的生活吧。我要做出那些让我先过好生活的生活选择，然后再去削减这些选择
to like, oh, I wanna be obscure. Sean had a similar moment. I was with him a couple years ago. There we go. And we were on, and Sean was, he gave me a ride on the G5 and he was, and he said we're gonna have. The G-Nickel. And they came out with ride on the G5. And he said, we're gonna have. The G-Nickel. And they came out with the G-Nickel
去迎合什么：哦，我想变得默默无闻。肖恩曾有过类似的时刻。几年前我和他在一起。这不。我们当时在，肖恩载我坐了一次G5私人飞机，然后他说我们要有……G-Nickel。然后他们带着……坐了一次G5。然后他说我们要有……G-Nickel
and they came out with the lobster. And he said, I got lobster. And I said, you're damn right, you did. Good for you. So we started eating the lobster and then he looked over and he realized that I was videotape him. I did, I ate lobster. I'm gonna last you a minute. I feel likeotape. I did.
然后他们拿出了……他们拿出了龙虾。然后他说：我有龙虾。我说：你说的对，确实有。真棒。于是我们开始吃龙虾，接着他转过头去，发现我正在用视频拍他。我确实拍了，我吃龙虾。我能吃你一分钟。我觉得我被拍了。我确实拍了。
I hate lobster. Isn't that one of the great, that's one of the caveats of fame and access or any kind of success? Is you say yes to things because a lot of times I'm like, I never had the option to say yes or no. You damn right the The answer's yes. And you got to ask yourself when they go,
我讨厌龙虾。难道这不是那种美妙的，那是成名和获得特权或任何成功带来的代价之一吗？就是你会对事情说“好”，因为很多时候我想：我以前从来没有说过“行”或“不行”的选择权。你说的对，答案就是“行”。而当他们问你时，你得问问自己：
do you want lobster on the Chief Five trip? And you're going like, I don't know. That's a little lobster for you. You got to ask yourself first. I like lobster. Yeah. Exactly. Well, on that Matthew, with, you know, you seem so genuinely authentic, honest.
你想在G5飞机上吃龙虾吗？然后你会想：我不知道。这龙虾对你来说有点多。你首先得问问自己。我喜欢龙虾。对。没错。好了，说到这个，马修，伴随着，你知道的，你看起来如此真诚、诚实。
We used the word vulnerable earlier. And it's something that I try to strive for too. I know Sean and Will do as well. And sometimes I feel like what we do for a living is at odds with that quest. In that, like the definition of what we do is, you know, we're professional liars. We're pretending to be somebody other than us. What's your level of comfort with
我们刚才用过“脆弱”这个词。这也是我一直在努力追求的。我知道肖恩和威尔也是。有时我觉得我们谋生的职业与这种追求是矛盾的。因为，我们所做的事情的定义是，你知道的，我们是专业的骗子。我们假装成除自己之外的其他人。你对这种状态的
that? Can you reconcile those two things? How have you been able to do that? Dude, I'm going to go with Bob Dylan on that one. This whole thing about, oh, I got to get to the truth of who I am. Dylan goes the opposite, he's like, man, we are who we create, whatever we create. We're all creations, you know? So I would also go to the extent that as much as, as you said, Bateman, we're inhabiting someone else. Yeah.
接受程度如何？你能调和这两者吗？你是怎么做到这一点的？老兄，关于这一点我得搬出鲍勃·迪伦了。整件事就是，哦，我必须找到我真实的自我。迪伦则反其道而行之，他说：老兄，我们创造了什么，我们就是什么。我们都是被创造出来的，你知道吗？所以我也要说，正如你所说，贝特曼，我们在扮演别人。对。
Tell me, man, you feel about this, but ultimately, we're being that part of ourselves. Right. Yeah. My version of you feel about this, but ultimately, we're being that part of ourself. Right. Yeah. My version of that person. Yeah. And so, you know, in that way, acting and performing is an absolute vacation. And an expansion of who we are.
告诉我，老兄，你对此有什么感觉，但归根结底，我们是在展现我们自身的那个部分。对。没错。我对那个角色的理解。对。所以，你知道的，从这个意义上说，演戏和表演绝对是一场假期。也是对我们自身的拓展。
Yeah. Really? Yeah. And you're exploring sort of the edges of it. Yeah. It's like the old Marantz equalizer. You turn up 500HKZ part of yourself. You turn down, if it's a Saturday night character, you turn down responsibility,
对。真的吗？对。而且你在探索它的边缘。对。就像老式的马兰士均衡器。你把你自己身上500赫兹的那部分调大。如果你在演一个周六晚上的角色，你把责任心调低，
and you turn down these other things. If it's a Monday morning character, and you're an astronaut, you turn up responsibility, and you turn up conscientiousness, and you lower the half hazard times. And you just, and then to go, go. Yeah. And then it's just trust in living in there and go
然后你把这些别的东西调低。如果是周一早上的角色，你是个宇航员，你把责任心调高，你把认真程度调高，然后把那些随心所欲的时刻调低。然后你只要，然后说：上。对。然后这就是信任并活在其中，去
and trust me, I've had plenty of roles that I got in that I'm like, when will this movie's over? Am I gonna come out of this? Because if I continue this, I'm going to jail. You know what I mean? Or whatever it is, you know what I'm gonna be a buddy dud, you know? And, you know, with all these incredible insights that you have, like who, I'm just be a buddy, Dad. You know? And, you know, with all these incredible insights
相信我，我有很多角色，进去之后我都在想：这部电影什么时候才结束啊？我能从这个角色里抽身出来吗？因为如果我再继续这样下去，我要进监狱了。你知道我的意思吗？或者诸如此类的，你知道我的意思，我要变成一个废柴了，对吧？而且，你知道的，凭借你所有这些不可思议的见解，比如谁，我只是看着你说话，听着你说的每一句话，到处闲逛。谁能让你兴致勃勃，只想和他们海阔天空地瞎聊、进行一场美妙的对话？我经常和孩子们进行这样的对话，随着他们慢慢长大。
that you have, like who, I'm just watching you talk and listening to everywhere and hanging out everywhere. Who do you, who gets your juices going, just having, shooting the shit, having a great conversation with? I've got those conversations with the kids as they get older.
我发现，我有一个16岁和一个11岁的女儿。对话变得越来越好了。比如，我发现，我有一个16岁、一个11岁的女儿。对话变得越来越好了。现在我和我女儿们进行着一些我最深入的对话。这太棒了。我也开始有这种感觉了。你注意到那种转变了吗，我们从单纯的父亲变成了既是父亲又是朋友。然后一旦你稍微切换到朋友的身份，你就可以有点像：行吧，告诉我吧，然后她们就能敞开心扉。她们不会担心后果，
I'm finding, I got a 16 year old and 11 year old daughters. The conversations get even better. Like, I'm finding, I got a 16 year old, 11 year old daughters. The conversations get even better. I'm having some of my closest conversations with who I am with my girls now. That's great. I start to have that too. You notice that transition we go from just being a father to being a father and a friend. And then as soon as you slip into that a bit of the friend, you can kind of be like, yeah, let me know, and they can slide. And they're not worried about the consequence,
或者担心如果我给出了错误的回答就会惹上麻烦，而你会有点像：行吧，告诉我吧。现在我来告诉你我当年是怎么样的。我们进行过关于初吻的讨论。哦，对，对。而且，你知道的，嗯，为了这个以及你是怎么做的。我就说：好吧，让我来告诉你我当年的事，老兄。自然小径。那个叫艾米的女孩出去了。
or if I give the wrong answer, I'm in trouble, where you're kinda like, yeah, let me know. And now let me tell you how that was with me. We've had the first kiss discussions. Oh yeah, yeah. And, you know, well, for this and how you do it. And I'm like, yeah, let me tell you about my first man, Nature Trail. Name of the Amy went out.
我当时特别兴奋。还有那个老，那个老，我忘那是哪部电影了，关于嘴唇的。叫做戴着牙套。不，我死去的。然后它们流血流得到处都是。而且你会。我们撞到鼻子了。
I was really excited. And that old, that old, I forget what movie it was with the lip. It's called on the braces. No, my dead. And they bled all over. And you will. And we bumped noses.
我不知道该往左还是往右。我来回假动作晃动。我退缩了，结果太糟了，老兄。然后我把我儿子逗笑了。他就说：相信我，在这件事上你们不需要表现得完美。慢慢来，巴拉巴拉。我刚刚也进行了同样的对话。
I didn't know whether to go left or right. And I doubled juke. And I flinched and it was not good man. So then I get my son laughing. And he's like, yeah, trust me, they don't have to try and be perfect on this thing. Just take your time, blah, blah, blah. I just had the same conversation.
我是和我儿子谈的，我去接我儿子。他去参加了这次旅行。所以他的妈妈和我，她就觉得，我说，我说，好吧，我去接他，我们在机场接了他。我们开车回家大约要开四个小时。这真的很棒，因为我不知道你们有没有注意到。我喜欢和孩子们一起开车的原因是，他们，
I had it with my son's and I picked my son up. He was on this trip. And so his mom and I, she was like, I was like, I'm like, yeah, I'll go pick him up and we picked him up the airport. We had like a four hour drive home. And it was great because I don't know if you guys notice. What I love driving with my kids is that they're,
你们两个都看着前方，而且他们在开车时往往更愿意分享心事。对。在长途旅行中，他们不觉得你在盯着他们看。因为你在看路。这就是为什么我不喜欢，
you're both looking forward and they tend to share more when we drive. Yeah. On a long journey, they don't have to, they don't feel you looking at them. Because you're looking at the road. That's why I don't like,
这就是为什么我比起FaceTime更喜欢打电话。我觉得打电话比FaceTime要真诚一些，对。我懂，我懂。你可以说，这也是为什么有些人实际上……我在疫情期间通过Zoom会议建立了一些关系，比起面对面，我其实更喜欢那种距离感。
that's why I prefer phone calls at a FaceTime. I feel like phone calls are a little bit more honest in FaceTime, yeah. I get that, I get that. You could argue that's why some people have actually, I've formed some relationships doing over COVID, doing Zoom meet that I like more from the distance than I was.
对，你们是面对面的。对，这说得通。对。但我确实发现那些联系，JB，就像你说的，与孩子们的那些联系，我不知道，让我想起，我想我跟你们说过，我和我其中一个儿子有过一次最棒的对话。
Yeah, you're in person. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. But I do find that those connections, JB, like you were saying, those connections with the kids in that, I don't know, reminds me, I think I told you guys, I had one of the greatest conversations with my son, one of my sons.
我不会说那是谁，因为我不想让他尴尬，但他几年前对我说过，我们坐在那里，我们正在花时间，我能看出他有点沮丧。那是一个星期天下午，我们到处转转，我们坐在那里，我能看出，他有点沮丧。那是一个星期天下午，我们到处转转，我们坐在那里，他坐在地上，
I won't say who, because I want to embarrass him, but he said to me a couple of years ago, we were sitting there, we were spending, I could tell he was kind of down. It was a Sunday afternoon, we went around, we were sitting there, and he was could tell you, it was kind of down. It was a Sunday afternoon, we went around, we were sitting there, and he was on the ground, and he has head in his hand, and I go, what's going on buddy?
双手抱头，我说：老弟，怎么了？
He goes, I just don't know where I, he looks up and he goes, I just don't know where I fit in. And the fact that he was able to be honest with me in that moment, and we ended up having this incredible conversation. And it was one of the great, I don't know where it ranked for him in his short life, but in my longer life,
他说：我就是不知道我……他抬起头说：我就是不知道我适合什么地方。而在那一刻，他能够对我说真话，我们最终进行了这样一场不可思议的对话。这是最棒的对话之一，我不知道在他短暂的人生中这能排到第几位，但在我较长的人生中，
it's one of the greatest conversations I've ever had. That's right, I love that. You know, I got a good friend in Austin, his name is Barton Ags, he's raised a few girls successfully out of his house. And he and I were talking just a few months ago, as my kids are hitting teens, and he's like, dude, there's just one thing you wanna do
这是我经历过的最棒的对话之一。没错，我太喜欢了。你知道，我在奥斯汀有个好朋友，他叫巴顿·阿格斯，他成功地把几个女儿抚养长大并送出了家门。就在几个月前，当我的孩子开始进入青少年时期时，我和他聊天，他说：老兄，不管怎样你都想做一件事，
whatever you can to maintain through these teen years. I go, what? He goes, access. To let him be honest like that and to be able to go, I don't know where I fit in. Yeah. You know, and it's true to pick it out on a spot where it's not, we're gonna sit down and talk.
在这些青少年时期尽一切可能去保持。我问：什么？他说：通道。让他们能够像那样诚实，能够说出“我不知道我适合什么地方”。对。你知道的，而且要在一个不是“我们要坐下来好好谈谈”的特定地点聊。
Look me in the eye. No, where it's a little more informal, to like we're driving, we're doing something or taking a walk, you do find that more. But to maintain some access to keep some honesty, you know, in these years, I'm hoping to do. Yeah, and I feel like that's the friendship part of the relationship, but then I feel,
看着我的眼睛。不，是在更非正式的场合，比如我们在开车、我们在做某事或者在散步时，你会发现这种情况更多。但为了保持某种通道、保持某种诚意，你知道的，在这些年里，我希望能做到这点。对，我觉得那是关系中属于朋友的部分，但有时候我，
I worry sometimes, well, am I sacrificing what could be more useful to them, which is parenting at the expense of sacrificing the friendship is like, so I battle with that sometimes, or trying to keep the access door open by being super friends. Yeah. But sometimes that's not helpful to them,
我有时会担心，我是不是牺牲了对他们更有用的一部分，也就是以牺牲友情为代价来行使父母的职责？所以我有时会为此纠结，或者试图通过当超级好朋友来保持通往他们内心的通道敞开。对。但有时这对他们并没有帮助，
because they've got friends, but they've only got one dad, one mom. That's a tough line to walk, man. I mean, I think the kids have such a great bullshit meter. They're born with it. And we wear it out as we get older, whatever, people, other people's society, whatever wears it out. And I think that what kids, I find in my experience,
因为他们有朋友，但他们只有一个爸爸、一个妈妈。这是一条很难把握的界限，老兄。我的意思是，我觉得孩子们有着极好的胡扯雷达。他们生来就带有这东西。而随着我们年龄增长，这雷达被磨损了，不管怎样，别人、社会，不管什么东西把它给磨损了。而我认为孩子们，以我的经验来看，
I'm not preaching anything, but my experience is that if you are honest with your kids in that way and you're authentic, we're talking about Matthew, about you being authentic. If you can be authentic in those moments, they get it and they can feel you being authentic. If you're not trying to get something from them, but you're just trying to relate to them, a relationship is just two people relating.
我不是在说教什么，但我的经验是，如果你以那种方式对你的孩子诚实，并且你是真诚的，就像我们刚才谈到马修你很真诚一样。如果你在那些时刻能够保持真诚，他们能懂，他们能感觉到你的真诚。如果你不是想从他们身上得到什么，而只是想和他们建立联系，一段关系其实就是两个人产生连接。
And if you can relate to them, they'll be honest with you, they'll share, they'll give you that access as long as you stay in that zone. Just keep it authentic. That's it. I think that's the key. I think. It sure helps. I mean, look, it's, you know, I don't know about you.
如果你能和他们产生连接，他们就会对你诚实，他们会分享，只要你待在这个区域里，他们就会向你敞开通道。只要保持真诚。就是这样。我觉得这就是关键。我觉得。这确实很有帮助。我是说，听着，这，你知道的，我不知道你们怎么样。
I was raised. Camille and I have much longer conversations with our kids than my parents had with me. I mean, my parents, you could talk about it, and I was the question, I was the why. What but how, but why? But why? Mom would entertain that a little bit,
我是被抚养长大的。卡米拉和我跟孩子们的对话比我父母当年跟我之间的对话要长得多。我的意思是，我的父母，你可以谈谈，而我就是那个问题宝宝，我就是那个“为什么”。什么、但是、怎么、但是为什么？但是为什么？妈妈还会稍微应付一下，
but very quickly within a few minutes, it became because I said so. Right, and I'm your parent. And that was it, conversation over. Yeah. It's that thing, because some conversations that you started 8 p.m., and you're gonna try to explain, you look up and it's 11.
但很快在几分钟内，这就变成了：因为我这么说。对，因为我是你家长。然后就这样了，谈话结束。对。就是那种情况，因为有些对话你晚上8点开始，你试图解释，一抬头发现已经11点了。
Yeah. And then it's midnight. And you're going, you're wearing me out here, man. It's like, because I said so, man, because I'm 53 and I'm your dad and you're 10. Go to bed. You know what I mean? Exactly.
对。然后就半夜了。而你在想：老兄，你把我折腾得够呛啊。这就像是：因为我这么说，老兄，因为我53岁了，我是你爸，你才10岁。去睡觉。你知道我的意思吗？完全正确。
Who's the disciplinarium between you and Camilla? Who's the parent? Who's the friend? Or do you guys switch off? Well, we try to watch the old good cop bad cop stuff. I mean, look, I got one daughter. And I'm guilty of probably being a little more on the lean inside of the daughter You know you only really ship that the honeymoon never ends, you know, right?
在你和卡米拉之间，谁是管纪律的恶人？谁是严父慈母？谁是朋友？还是你们俩会轮流扮演？嗯，我们尽量注意那种老套的好警察坏警察的戏码。我是说，听着，我有一个女儿。而我可能有点罪过，在对待女儿这方面稍微有点偏向溺爱，你知道的，只有这种关系是蜜月期永远不会结束的，对吧？
So but I mean It's it's Camille's more day-to-day moment to moment. I'm a little more like guys gang We've you've been stretching that aren't a little bit, I'm starting, the little things you're adding up, I'm gonna step in here and I'll go in and be general. And I'll sit down in the general and they're like,
所以，但我的意思是，卡米拉更多负责日常的、每时每刻的管教。我更像是那种：伙计们，帮派们，你们刚才有点越界了，我开始觉得，你们加起来的小毛病越来越多了，我要介入了，我要化身将军了。然后我会以将军的姿态坐下来，他们就会：
oh, all right. And it's like, no, this is how it's going down right now. And I've had to talk with them, this one's a great one. When, and this is helped with my boys is going, you know, if I let you get away with that with your mother, what is that teaching you to allow your son to do to the woman you're gonna fall in love with? Right.
哦，好吧。然后就会变成：不，事情现在就要这么办。我不得不和他们谈谈，这个例子特别棒。当——这对我教育儿子很有帮助——我说：你知道的，如果我纵容你那样对待你母亲，那是在教导你如何允许你的儿子去那样对待你未来深爱的女人吗？对。
You know, and then to go cut even deeper and more direct is, boys, that's my wife. Right. What kind of husband might teach you to be if I let you get away with that? Right. Do they hear that? That one actually cut into places where they understood it. In ways that I thought it was gonna be too above their head.
你知道的，然后更深入、更直接地说：孩子们，那是我的妻子。对。如果我纵容你们那样对她，我是在教导你们成为什么样的丈夫？对。他们听进去了吗？那番话真的切中了他们的要害，让他们听懂了。以一种我原以为会超出他们理解能力的方式。
But I called it personal. I said, this is the woman that I fell in love with that I've married and we got together and made y'all, man. And if I'm letting you get away with that, let you disrespect her. What kind of husband might teach you to husband am I teaching you to be? And they were like, whoa, it became sort of a bit of a, you know, with the boys, it became a little bit of a,
但我把它说得很私人。我说：这是我深爱并娶回家的女人，我们走到一起才生下了你们这群小兔崽子。如果我纵容你们那样做，允许你们不尊重她，那我到底在教你们成为什么样的丈夫？他们就会：哇，这开始变成了一种，你知道的，对于男孩子来说，这开始变成了一种，
oh, that's my responsibility. Yeah, yeah, as you're son. Yeah, so. But it's kind of fun that like now, they're old enough now to really intellectualize that kind of thing and finish that sentence, you know, that you started for them, you know, that's, yeah.
哦，那是我的责任。对，对，作为你的儿子。对，所以。但这也挺有趣的，现在他们长大了，真的能够理智地思考这种事情，并且能把你们为他们开头的那些话给接上，你知道的，这就叫，对。
We'll be right back. Smartlet's get support from Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors or spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Most people think they're spending $80 on their subscriptions when in reality the number is closer on their subscriptions. When in reality,
我们马上回来。SmartLess受到Rocket Money的大力支持。Rocket Money是一款个人财务应用程序，可以帮你查找并取消不需要的订阅，监控支出，并在一个地方帮你降低账单。大多数人都以为自己的订阅费每月大约是80美元，而实际上这个数字更接近他们的订阅费。而实际上，
the number is closer to $200. When you're signed up for so many things, like streaming services where you used to watch one show or free trials for delivery you don't use, it's so easy to lose track of what you're paying for. With rocket money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service. Rocket money does all the work for you. Rocket money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketm money.com slash smartless. That's rocket money.com slash smartless.
这个数字接近200美元。当你注册了太多服务时，比如你看某一个节目的流媒体服务，或者你根本不用的外卖服务的免费试用，你很容易忘记自己在为哪些东西花钱。通过Rocket Money，只需按一下按钮，你就可以轻松取消那些你不需要的订阅。再也不用忍受长时间的等待或是给客服发令人烦恼的电子邮件了。Rocket Money会为你代劳一切。Rocket Money甚至可以帮你协商，将账单降低最多20%。你只需拍下账单的照片，剩下的就交给Rocket Money处理吧。不要再把钱浪费在不用 东西上。取消不需要的订阅，以轻松的方式管理你的资金，请访问 rocketmoney.com/smartless。网址是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。网址是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。
Rocket money.com slash smartless. Smartless get support from Helix. Ugh, it's so nice to be back in my own bad sleeping on my Helix dusk looks mattress. It's the best sleep I've ever had. The helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released helix Elite Collection,
rocketmoney.com/smartless。SmartLess得到Helix的大力支持。哦，回到自己的床上，睡在我的Helix Dusk Luxe床垫上，感觉太棒了。这是我睡过最舒服的觉。Helix产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、
a mattress design for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Let's talk about the new high-end helix Elite Collection. It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online, don't be. The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you. And your personalized mattresses ship straight to your door free of charge.
专为高大体型睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专门为儿童制造的床垫。让我们来谈谈全新高端的Helix Elite系列。它包括六种不同的床垫型号，每一种都专为特定的睡眠姿势和软硬偏好量身定制。害怕在线购买床垫？大可不必。Helix睡眠测试会综合考虑你的个人睡眠偏好，为你和伴侣匹配最完美的床垫。而且你个性化定制的床垫会免费直接运送到你的门前。
Plus, Helix mattresses all come with a 10 or 15-year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleap.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet, and it won't last long with Helix better sleep starts now. SmartList is supported by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible
此外，根据型号不同，所有Helix床垫都享有10年或15年的质保。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头。请访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们有史以来最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久，通过Helix，优质睡眠从现在开始。SmartLess由Audible支持。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你最爱的精选内容或发现全新的内容。Audible
offers an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre. You'll find guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities renowned experts, and exciting new voices in audio. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere, while traveling, working out,
提供涵盖各种流派的令人难以置信的有声书精选。你会找到引导式健康节目、戏剧表演、喜剧，以及来自顶级名人、知名专家和音频领域激动人心的新声音的独家Audible原创新作。作为Audible会员，你可以从整个目录中选择一个月的标题永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新发布的作品。Audible应用程序让你随时随地都能轻松聆听，无论是旅行、健身、
walking, doing chores, you decide. So I've been checking out Atomic Habits by James Clear. I love his last name, it's so apropos. It's a great, great audiobook. It'll teach you exactly how to form good habits, break bad ones, and master the tiny behaviors that lead to amazing, amazing results. I really, really highly recommend it. You know, we always joke about on the podcast how we don't read, but listening to an audiobook
散步还是做家务，都由你决定。所以我一直在看詹姆斯·克利尔（James Clear）写的《原子习惯》（Atomic Habits）。我喜欢他的姓氏，太贴切了。这是一本非常非常棒的有声书。它会确切地教你如何养成好习惯、戒掉坏习惯，并掌握那些能带来惊人成果的微小行为。我真的非常非常强烈地向大家推荐。你知道的，我们在播客里总是开玩笑说我们不读书，但听有声书
seems to be more time efficient for us, and I really, really enjoy actually listening to books. It's fantastic. I'm reading again with my ears. New members can try Audible Free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible Free for 30 days. Audible. for 30 days audible.com slash SmartLess.
对我们来说似乎更省时，而且我真的非常非常享受听书的过程。这太棒了。我又开始用耳朵读书了。新成员可以免费体验Audible 30天。请访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。网址是 audible.com/smartless，或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，即可免费试用Audible 30天。Audible。免费试用30天，请访问 audible.com/smartless。
All right, back to the show. So wait, Matthew, I asked you this like five minutes ago, but you were all, you were thinking about it. I don't wanna put you in the spot, so you don't have to answer if you don't want. But you know, you have so much to share and to teach and through your just incredible brain. Who is your guru? Do you have somebody in your life? You're like,
好的，我们回到节目中。等等，马修，我大概五分钟前问过你这个问题，但你当时一直在思考。我不想让你难堪，所以如果你不想回答，也可以不回答。但是，你知道的，你有那么多的见解可以分享和传授，凭借你那不可思议的大脑。谁是你的导师？你生活中有没有这样一个人，你会觉得：
God, you know what? I got to listen to this guy, or you have the greatest conversations where you actually walk away learning something. Because like I said, I learned from you all the time just watching your Instagram. I don't have a certain person. I have in the last five years started to seek out elder mentors in a way that I didn't before. Yeah, that's what I mean. And look, ironically, I was writing about it last night. I'm losing my mentors. They're dying.
天哪，你知道吗？我必须听这个人的话，或者你和他们有过最棒的对话，以至于你离开时真的学到了东西。因为就像我说的，我看着你的Instagram，无时无刻不在向你学习。我没有特定某个人。但在过去的五年里，我开始以一种以前没有过的方式寻找年长的导师。对，这就是我的意思。而且，具有讽刺意味的是，我昨晚还在写这个。我在失去我的导师。他们在离去。
Over this last four years, I don't know, I've been for y'all, but I've had some elder friends that were right there. They slowed down, but they were right there holding it. Boy, that last, all of a sudden the drop is steep and they're gone. Has that triggered for you something? And I'm not prying for an answer on the on the specifics, but at least for
在过去的四年里，我不知道，对你们来说怎么样，但我有一些年长的朋友就在那里。他们放慢了脚步，但他们就坐在那里坚持着。天哪，最后，突然之间，下滑变得陡峭，他们就这么走了。这为你触发了什么吗？我并不是想打听具体细节，但至少对我
me, you know, for all four of us, we're we're closer death than we are to birth. And at some point, especially if you're semi intelligent, like I think the four of us are, you do start to think about, well, what are some of the things I want to when that moment of clarity comes where you're like, okay, here I am in the last week. I'm in hospice or whatever the hell it is. When everyone gets to the end of their life,
来说，你知道的，对我们四个人而言，我们距离死亡比距离出生更近。在某个时刻，特别是如果你稍微有点智力，就像我觉得我们四个人这样，你确实会开始思考，那么，当那种清晰的时刻到来，你心想“好吧，我在这里，我正处于人生的最后一周。我在安宁疗护病房，或者不管那到底是什么鬼东西”时，有哪些事情是我希望自己能做的？当每个人走到生命的尽头时，
what are some of the things I'm gonna wish? I can say yes, I did that, yes, I did that. Are you starting to think about some of those things? Am I being the kind of adult I wanted to be? Am I... I started doing that about about six years ago. There's part of the reason I think I wrote the book, Greenlight.
我会有哪些希望自己能做到的事情？我可以自豪地说：是的，我做过那个；是的，我做过那个。你开始思考这些事情了吗？我有在成为我想成为的那种成年人吗？我有……我大约在六年前就开始这么做了。我想这也是我写《绿灯》这本书的部分原因。
I started to get the courage enough to project to my deathbed, to my eulogy and go, what's it gonna be, man? Where's your head and heart and spirit gonna be? What's your legacy gonna be? How are you gonna look back? What are people gonna say? How are you gonna be introduced after you're gone?
我开始积聚足够的勇气，去想象我临终时的情景，想象我的悼词，然后心想：老兄，结果会怎样？你的头脑、心脏和精神会在哪里？你的传奇会是什么？你将如何回首往事？人们会怎么说？你离去之后，别人会如何向大家介绍你？
Right. And we think that's morose. No. But if it's inevitable, how can it be morose? Right. Because it's going to happen to everybody, right? So to look at it, and if anything, it's giving me more of a charge to go. Okay.
对。而我们觉得这很阴郁。不。但如果这是不可避免的，怎么能说是阴郁呢？对。因为这会发生在大。家身上，对吧？所以去直视它，如果说它带来了什么，那就是给了我更多的动力去心想：好吧。
Right. Well, let's make this shit count. Yeah, but most people with your success would be, yeah, I did it. I think they're going to live forever. They just kicked the can down the road. I won't say who this is, but somebody super duper successful. I was talking to the other day and I was asking him about his health regimen. And he was like, yeah, you know what, here's a deal.
好吧，让我们把这些破事过得有意义。对，但大多数人如果取得了你这样的成功，就会觉得：对，我做到了。我想他们会觉得自己能长生不老。他们只是把问题往后拖延。我不会说是谁，但有个超级无敌成功的人。我前几天跟他聊天时，问起他的健康养生之道。然后他说：对，你知道吗，事情是这样的……
I don't know what your religious belief is, but I believe that we all kind of come around, we do multiple laps. You know, we're always working on things, you know, reincarnation, whatever the hell it is. But he says, I like this lap. I started laughing because this guy's like enormously successful.
我不知道你的宗教信仰是什么，但我相信我们都会经历轮回，经历多世。你知道的，我们总是在不断完善自己，你知道的，不管是轮回转世还是什么鬼。但他说，我喜欢这一世。我忍不住笑了，因为这家伙取得了巨大的成功。
He says, I just don't want this to end. Like, I'm having a really good time. And I want to eat, yeah. By the way, spending time with all those, like anytime you get around any kind of those sort of billionaire types or whatever, the one thing I know that they all talk about is their mortality and their fucking health.
他说，我只是不想这一切结束。因为我过得真的很开心。我还想吃，对。顺便说一句，和那些人花时间在一起，无论什么时候你接触到任何那种亿万富翁类型的人或者其他什么人，他们所有人谈论的一件事就是他们的生死和他们该死的健康。
It's it, it's all the time, because it's the one thing they can't buy. They're not thinking about it. They're like, they can improve it. I look at, I've got these mountains of cash, but I can't buy immortality. You're not fucking like, no, man, no, dude, you're gonna die just like everybody fucking else. The other thing is, I also know, I, you know, these guys know my good buddy died a few
就是这个，无时无刻不在谈论，因为这是他们买不到的唯一东西。他们没有在想别的。他们觉得，他们可以改善它。我看看，我有堆积如山的现金，但我买不到永生。你才没有像，不，老兄，不，哥们，你也会死，就像其他所有人他妈的一样。另一件事是，我也知道，我，你知道，这些人知道我好朋友在几个月前去世了，
months ago, a childhood pal, and it's kind of really, it's made me ask a lot of questions in the last few months. And the one thing I realized is like, we all know the deal. The deal is we're all gonna die. We just kick the can down the road to work out this day. We kick it down the road and we trick ourselves and what happens to go, hey, so and so died.
一个童年玩伴，这真的让我在这几个月里提出了很多问题。我意识到的一件事是，我们都知道这个结局。结局就是我们都会死。我们只是把问题往后拖，来度过每一天。我们把问题往后拖，自欺欺人，然后突然发生了一件事，就像，嘿，某某死了。
What? Yeah. Yeah. It's just so bright. What do you think was gonna have? Unbelievable. Unbelievable. He died. He didn't live to a thousand. just. What do you think was going unbelievable?
什么？对。对。太突然了。你以为会发生什么？难以置信。难以置信。他死了。他没活到一千岁。简直。你以为会发生什么，难以置信。
He died. He didn't live to a thousand. Yeah, you know, Joan River said like just a few months before she died. She's like, I made he sex when I dying. Nobody's going to go so soon. Right. Yeah. But wait, I want to hit a hundred. So bad. Oh, God.
他死了。他没活到一千岁。对，你知道的，琼·里弗斯在她去世前几个月说过。她说，我希望我在死的时候正在做爱。没有人会那么快离开。对。对。但等等，我太想活到一百岁了。哦，天哪。
I really do. Yeah. Do you really? I've just got a numbers game. Just pure ego. That's the number. I really want to hit a hundred so bad. Oh god. I really do. Yeah. Do you really? He's got a numbers game. Just pure ego. That's the number. I really want to get to a hundred. I do feel like this generation will do that more commonly than the last.
我是认真的。对。你真的是吗？这对我来说只是一场数字游戏。纯粹的虚荣。这就是那个数字。我太想活到一百岁了。哦，天哪。我是认真的。对。你真的是吗？他这只是一场数字游戏。纯粹的虚荣。这就是那个数字。我真的很想活到一百岁。我觉得这一代人比上一代人更容易做到这一点。
Yeah. I feel like we got. I mean, with your diet of nuts and cardboard, your interns look like you're a hundred and don't worry. I use you to pack my clothes here in New York. But with your success, don't you? I'm just going back to what you said about what's my legacy. What am I going to leave behind?
对。我觉得我们有。我是说，以你那种吃坚果和纸板的饮食，你的实习生看起来就像你已经一百岁了，别担心。我用你来打包我在纽约的衣服。但以你的成功，难道你——我只是回到你刚才说的关于我的传奇是什么。我要留下什么？
But my God, the body of work is mind blowing. It's really more than any actor. It's the top of the heap. So what else is there to accomplish in your mind that would make you feel like now I have enough to leave behind. Now I have a legacy. Now I have something for people to introduce me as as you say. Well, I mean, my negotiables are different forms of art, but manan negotiables are those three kids I was talking about. Yeah, yeah. I hope that when they are out of the house
但是天哪，那些作品简直太震撼了。这真的是任何演员都无法比拟的。这是顶峰。那么在你的心目中，还有什么可完成的事情能让你觉得，现在我有足够的遗产留下来了。现在我有了传奇。现在我有了可以让人家用来介绍我的身份的东西，正如你所说。嗯，我是说，我的非谈判条件是不同形式的艺术，但真正的非谈判条件是我刚才谈到的那三个孩子。对，对。我希望当他们离开家的时候，
and as they become adults and after I'm gone, that they'll be able to list me, that the three of them will be able to list me as best friend on one hand, one of their five top best friends. Oh, that's great. That's a dream of mine. That's awesome.
当他们成为成年人并且我离开之后，他们能够把我在某种程度上列为最好的朋友，把我在他们前五名最好的朋友中列为其中一个。哦，那太棒了。那是我的梦想。那太棒了。
You know, and that gets into that friendship thing we were talking about, but I can't go full-bore on that yet. I still do have to be a parent. I still do have to give myself credit and go, I'm a father for a reason. In 53, we have, if we don't know better, what's evolution for at the same time trying to be that friend and hope him on their own.
你知道的，这就谈到了我们刚才讨论的友谊问题，但我现在还不能全力以赴地去那样做。我仍然必须当好一个家长。我仍然必须肯定自己，然后心想，我当父亲是有原因的。在53岁时，如果我们不懂得更多，那么在努力成为那个朋友并希望他们独立的同时，演化的意义何在？
Yeah, it also, for me at least, it kind of demands that I live my life in a way that they can maintain respect for me, which translates to friendship usually. I mean, you know, or I put another way, I'm not really close friends with anybody that I don't deeply respect. Right. So it's a good safeguard against, you know,
对，对我来说至少也是这样，它在某种程度上要求我以一种他们能保持对我的尊重的方式生活，这通常就会转化为友谊。我的意思是，你知道的，或者换句话说，我和任何我不深深尊重的人都不是真正的挚友。对。所以这是一个很好的保障，可以防止，你知道的，
letting your life run off the rails if you're really trying to hold the respect and friendship of people you care about. And then I'm trying to double down on whatever respect I've earned and gained. I'm trying to double down on that. I mean, there's, look, let's be honest, there's the baseline of who pays a rent, who puts the food on the table, who's giving you a chance to get an education, who's up in the middle of the night
如果你真的想保持你所关心的人对你的尊重和友谊，就不会让你的生活脱轨。然后我正试图加倍投入我所赢得和获得的一切尊重。我正试图对此进行加倍投入。我是说，看，老实说，这里有一个基准，是谁在付房租，是谁把食物端上桌，是谁在给你接受教育的机会，是谁在半夜醒来
taking care of you when you're sick, who's... Yeah, because I'm tired of it. Right, I'm tired. You're sick and tired of it. And they have to know that that's not just like... Over it. This is in just one way, straight. This is, and then we talked to him a lot about
在你生病时照顾你，是谁……对，因为我受够了。没错，我累了。你又病又累。而且他们必须知道这不仅仅是……受够了。这不只是单方面的，直来直去的。这是，然后我们和他们谈了很多关于
how did we get what success that we've had? We talk about winning the right way. We talk about, is there been luck along with you? Damn right. Has there been trying to do it well? Is trying to be as competent as a craft as I could be? Their mother as well. Yes there has.
我们是如何取得我们所取得的成功的？我们谈论以正确的方式赢得胜利。我们谈论，这其中有没有运气的成分？当然有。有没有努力把它做好？是不是在努力将手艺做到我能做到的最高水平？他们的母亲也是如此。是的，确实有。
But what's that saying about luck? Luck is the result of preparation and discipline or something like that. Yeah, some of the... I don't know. I talked to my son yesterday about this idea. I was saying, he was talking about cool kids
但关于运气是怎么说的来着？运气是准备和纪律的结果，诸如此类。对，有些……我不知道。我昨天和我的儿子谈过这个想法。我说，他当时在谈论学校里那些酷小孩
in school and stuff and I said, man, just do what makes you feel happy. I said, if you can be, and he started painting a lot in the last year and a half and I said, do that. If you can live a life where you get to be creative and you can do that on a daily basis, that's what you do. Yeah, yeah. You'll be so lucky.
之类的事情，我说，老兄，只管去做那些让你感到快乐的事。我说，如果你能，他过去一年半里开始画很多画，我说，去做那个。如果你能过这样一种生活，能够发挥创造力并且每天都能做到这一点，那就是你应该做的事。对，对。那你可太幸运了。
You'll be so happy in your life, no matter what the sort of the outcome is. And I go, and if you wanna know what success is, and I always say this to them, if you wanna know what success is, and I pull up my phone and I show them the video of Sean eating lobster on a G5. I go, this is success.
无论结果如何，你在生活中都会非常快乐。我说，如果你想知道什么是成功，我总是这样对他们说，如果你想知道什么是成功，我掏出手机，向他们展示肖恩在G5私人飞机上吃龙虾的视频。我说，这就是成功。
I do what it's got to be. Yeah, that's going to be good. Can I peel it for you? Yeah. Wait a second. We've taxed you so much, but I want to ask you one thing, because I want to get into the Greenlight Initiative or the foundation that you and your wife started,
我做到了该做的事。对，那会很棒。要我帮你剥吗？对。等一下。我们问了你太多问题，但我想问你一件事，因为我想谈谈“绿灯倡议”或者你和你妻子创立的基金会，
and what you guys are doing. It's so fucking cool. Tell the guys a little bit about what it is. Check this out, man. This is pretty cool and it's low hanging fruit. Yeah. But you know what I say about low hanging fruit? Still fruit.
以及你们正在做的事情。这太他妈酷了。跟伙计们稍微讲讲这是什么。看这个，老兄。这非常酷，而且是唾手可得的果实。对。但你知道我对唾手可得的果实怎么说吗？它依然是果实。
Pick it. And still fruit. You know? So, first bill by Parsons and Safety Communities Act has passed just over a year ago, right, to Safe and Schools. First one passed in 30 years. So billions of dollars of federal money are there to safe and schools, middle health counselors,
去摘吧。而且依然是果实。你知道吗？所以，帕森斯和安全社区法案的第一项法案在一年多前刚刚通过，对吧，为了让学校更安全。30年来通过的第一项。所以有数十亿美元的联邦资金用于学校安全、心理健康辅导，
and even physically safe and schools, like middle detectors, panic buttons, et cetera. Our congressman in Texas, who down there in Yvalda, where the shooting was, where I went, when Camilla and I went down,
甚至学校的物理安全，比如金属探测器、恐慌按钮等等。我们在德克萨斯州的国会议员，也就是那个发生枪击案的尤瓦尔迪的议员，我去过那里，当卡米拉和我去那里的时候，
comes to me four months after. And says, Matthew, I got 119 school districts. Eight, I think it's eight, have applied for a grant and zero have been awarded. Look what? We find out another out of 13,800 school districts in America for this very popular grant from the Department of Justice at Safe and Schools.
在四个月后来找我。说，马修，我有119个学区。有八个，我觉得是八个，申请了补助金，而获得资助的为零。看，什么？我们发现美国另外的13,800个学区中，对于司法部这项非常受欢迎的“安全学校”补助金。
405 applications. Total. 235 awarded grants. The math doesn't add up. You're like, what's going on? When we started studying this, and finally, I was amazed at how many school districts don't even know that the grants are there to apply for.
总共405个申请。235个获得了补助。这个数学算不对啊。你会想，这到底是怎么回事？当我们开始研究这个时，最后，我惊讶于有那么多学区甚至不知道有这些补助金可以申请。
Number two, the ones that do know are superintendents who are in the ones that need it in high poverty rate schools. The superintendents is the bus driver and the PE teacher. He doesn't have, he or she doesn't have the damn time or the expertise to write out one of these 50-page grants. And I understand that I can't even feel out of customs form with that scratch and shit out.
第二点，那些知道的学区，其总监是那些贫困率高的学校里的人。这个总监既是校车司机又是体育老师。他，或者她，根本没有该死的时间或专业知识来写出一份长达50页的申请书。我理解，我连海关申报单都填不好，上面涂涂改改的。
And they're complicated, they're really complicated. So they're like, I might even go write the grant. There's also people that are like, that's federal money. And that money's blue right now and I'm red, so I don't want that money. I'm like, guys, the money ain, blue, blue, blue, red, it's fucking green. You spend it.
而且它们很复杂，真的很复杂。所以他们会想，我甚至都不想去写这个申请。还有人会觉得，那是联邦资金。那些钱现在是蓝色的，而我是红色的，所以我不要那些钱。我说，伙计们，钱不是蓝色的，不是蓝、蓝、红，它他妈的是绿色的。花它就行了。
It's there. And the government wants you to spend it. Want you to get awarded. So the billions of dollars are there. Then we find out that it's used or lose it. And to year 2026, if these billions of dollars are not allocated, it'll be reallocated somewhere else. And we'll look back at this bipartisan
钱就在那里。政府希望你把它花掉。希望你能获得资助。所以数十亿美元都在那里。然后我们发现那是“不用就作废”的资金。到2026年，如果这数十亿美元没有被分配出去，就会被重新分配到其他地方。我们将回首这项两党
and safe community's act, which has already done some good, but we'll look back and go, so much of that bill was symbolic. And bravo to us, first one past in 28 years, and what do we do with it? So we started this Greenlight's Grand Initiative to help follow through as private citizens working with the public government to say, hey, let's cut through that red tape. 165 of the highest poverty rate schools in America are main target. We will have a full grant writing service
安全社区法案，它确实已经发挥了一些好作用，但我们会回过头来看，发现该法案的很大一部分都只是象征性的。我们真棒，28年来通过的第一项，而我们用它做了什么？所以我们启动了这项“绿灯补助倡议”，作为普通公民与公共政府合作进行后续跟进，旨在说，嘿，让我们打破那些繁文缛节。美国105所贫困率最高的学校是我们的主要目标。我们将提供全面的补助金撰写服务，
for those schools to file a grant that will most likely get awarded by the government to save from their schools. That's great, so you write the grant for them. We have grant writers who can write it for them. The second tier is, we have website now that walks you through. So the second tier of poverty schools can go on
为这些学校申请补助，使之最有可能获得政府资助，从而保障他们学校的安全。那太棒了，所以你们替他们写申请。我们有专门的补助金撰写人可以替他们写。第二层级是，我们现在有一个网站可以一步步引导你。所以第二层级的贫困学校可以登录，
and we have someone who will help you write the grant. And then the third place is just for the schools that are more fluent, but it just helps you get through the red tape process in a very simple way. So it's sort of, I call it a civics class of supply and demand. I mean, no, civics is not sexy. You know, as I'm saying, there's nothing glamorous about this I mean, it's, no, it's civics, it's not sexy. You know what I'm saying? This is, no, there's nothing glamorous
我们有人会帮你写申请。然后第三个层级是针对那些资金更充足的学校，但它只是通过非常简单的方式帮你走完繁文缛节的流程。所以这有点像，我称之为一堂关于供求关系的公民课。我是说，不，公民课可不性感。你知道的，就像我说的，这没有什么光鲜亮丽的，我是说，不，这是公民课，它不性感。你知道我在说什么吗？这，不，这个倡议没有什么光鲜亮丽的
about this initiative, but it's useful and it's constructive and it just needs to be there. It just needs to be there. And I, we had no idea how much the government's like, yes, we want to spend the money. We just have to feel the need. We have to feel, F-E-E-L, the need. And where help and schools go better over here going,
地方，但它很有用，很有建设性，而且它就是需要存在。它就是需要存在。而我，我们根本不知道政府有多么渴望说，是的，我们想把钱花出去。我们只需要感受到需求。我们需要感受到，感-受-到这种需求。而那些学校在这一边求助时却在说，
we need, but how do I show you we need you? Well, we're gonna help you feel that this grant that shows them. That's great. That you need it. And then they can add it. What's it called again? Green light grant initiative.
我们需要，但我该如何向你证明我们需要呢？好吧，我们将帮你感受到这份能向他们展示的补助金。太棒了。证明你们需要它。然后他们就可以加上它。这叫什么来着？绿灯补助倡议。
And can people go to a site and help out or how are you guys funded? You can go, we're still going around for looking for funding now. You know, one of the challenges has been people, a lot of people come up and wanted to fund, but they specifically wanted it to go towards their city or their state, which is a very interesting thing.
人们可以访问网站并提供帮助吗？或者你们的资金是怎么来的？你可以访问，我们现在仍在四处寻找资金。你知道，其中一个挑战是人们，很多人主动提出想要资助，但他们特别希望资金能够用在他们自己的城市或州，这是一个非常有趣的情况。
I mean, talk about, you know, this is a nonpolitical issue because it's a bipartisan bill that has passed. You still have people that go, well, I just want to put it in my backyard. It's a national campaign. If you go on the site, there are places where we can, we let you know you can help. There are places where we take donations to help. It'll tell you how much that donation, what it would pay for.
我是说，谈到，你知道的，这是一个非政治性问题，因为它是一项已经通过的两党法案。你仍然会有人说，嗯，我只想把它投在我家后院。这是一场全国性的运动。如果你访问这个网站，上面有我们可以让你知道如何提供帮助的地方。有些地方我们接受捐款来提供帮助。它会告诉你捐款的金额，以及它能支付什么。
18 to 25, G pays for a full grant writer to write. We have this grant writing firm that can do it by scale and lower their prices to do it by scale. Seems like it makes sense for the government to just peel off a tiny sliver of that huge allocation to fund a service to lubricate it, you know, like you guys are doing. Yes, I mean, they admit that there's too much retic-
1.8万到2.5万美元，可以支付一名全职补助金撰写人的费用。我们有这样一家补助金撰写公司，可以通过规模化作业来降低他们的价格。政府似乎只要从那笔巨额拨款中分出一小薄片，来资助一项精简流程的服务，就像你们在做的那样，这就很有意义。是的，我是说，他们承认有太多的繁文缛节——
the Rs and the Ds admit this should not be this complicated. Yeah. As we know, the government needs some help and run in their business. And this is an example of a private sector going, hey, we're not going to do it for you, but let's help you out. Well, they should donate to your site then. You know, the federal government should make a little donation there to help it run. We have a solid bipartisan advisory board from Murphy to Corning to many others. And they want, and they'd say if we could get to 165 of the highest risk schools and get them grants written
共和党人和民主党人也承认这不应该这么复杂。是的。正如我们所知，政府在运营业务方面确实需要一些帮助。这就是私营部门挺身而出说“嘿，我们不会替你做这件事，但我们可以帮你们一把”的一个例子。好吧，那他们应该向你们的网站捐款才对。你知道，联邦政府应该在那里捐一小笔款来帮助它运转。我们有一个坚实的两党顾问委员会，从墨菲到康宁再到许多其他人。他们希望，并且他们说如果我们能覆盖165所风险最高的学校并帮他们写好补助金申请
and get them awarded, that that would be a real, the Department of Education said that would be a massive game changer. And then the idea is that down the road, you don't need to have a full grant writer write these things out. That the process will be much more streamlined that, you know, maybe AI down the road can help fill out these grants. And you don't have to pay a certain person. We've also gone out. If anyone out there's listen, is a grant writer
并获得资助，那将是一个真正的，教育部说那将是一个巨大的游戏规则改变者。然后我们的想法是，在未来，你不需要有专门的补助金撰写人来写这些东西。这个过程将会大大简化，你知道的，也许未来人工智能可以帮忙填写这些补助申请。而你不需要付钱给某个人。我们也发出了呼吁。如果外面有任何人听到这番话，是一位补助金撰写人
and wants to do some pro bono work, please? Can you retire? Tim, Tim's a home phone number. Home phone numbers, coming up on screen right now. That's a great way to do it. Yeah, there are any great writers out there. And please do reach out to, they can't go to greenlightsgrananissive.org. You spent all this time, you do all this stuff and you do all this amazing stuff and giving back in this,
并且愿意做一些公益工作，拜托？你能退休吗？蒂姆，蒂姆的住宅电话号码。住宅电话号码，现在正显示在屏幕上。这是个好方法。是的，如果有任何优秀的补助金撰写人。请务必联系，他们可以访问 greenlightsgrantinitiative.org。你花了这么多时间，你做了所有这些事情，你做了所有这些了不起的事情并回馈社会，在这个——
we're not just giving back. I mean really Taking an initiative and helping Sean by the way, where was that lobster from on the G5? So that was a main Main star is yeah up north. I'm just to the right. Yeah good for you. Yeah Anyway, Matthew you do so as good work out there in the world He doesn't do oysters because oysters only have pearls No, it was diamonds It doesn't.
我们不仅仅是在回馈社会。我是说真的是在采取行动并帮助肖恩，顺便问一下，G5飞机上的那个龙虾是从哪里来的？那是缅因州的。缅因州海鲜，对，在北方。就在右边。对，真不错。对，不管怎样，马修，你在世界上做了那么多出色的工作。他不吃生蚝，因为生蚝只有珍珠——不，那是钻石。它不——
It doesn't. I mean, it doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't.
它不。我是说，它不。它不。它不。它不。它不。它不。
It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't.
它不。它不。它不。它不。It不。它不。它不。它不。它不。
It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn't. It doesn, so this is gonna, you don't have to talk about this. We can cut it. It's an old topic for any fun theater stories. Oh, oh,
它不。它不。它不。它不。它不。它不，所以这个，你不用谈这个。我们可以剪掉。对于任何有趣的戏剧故事来说，这是一个老话题。哦，哦，
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, we can cut it. But the only reason I'm bringing it up is because it has been a fantasy of mine. Is there, I know you said, Longo's naked? No, I have that meme. It's on repeat. But, but the Texas thing, will you ever revisit even the idea of Texas or better yet running for the president of this country or anything in politics at all? In politics. It would be amazing. Yeah. Look, it's not something I want to visit now because of what I said earlier.
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，我们可以把它剪掉。但我提起它的唯一原因是因为这一直是我的幻想。有没有，我知道你说的，朗格光着身子？不，我那个表情包。一直在循环播放。但是，但是关于德克萨斯的事，你是否会重新考虑甚至哪怕是德克萨斯的概念，或者更好的是竞选这个国家的总统，或者涉足任何政治活动？涉足政治。那会太棒了。对。听着，这不是我现在想考虑的事，因为我刚才说过的话。
Yeah. I'm raising three children right now and it's a great adventure doing that. I want to see that through. My only thing I ever knew I wanted to be with his dad since I was eight years old. I want to see that through. Yeah. And I have to measure as I've given great measurement to it. Where can I be most useful? And I want to enjoy myself.'ve given great measurement to it. Where can I be most useful?
对。我现在正在抚养三个孩子，这是一场很棒的冒险。我想把它进行到底。我一生中唯一知道自己想做的事，从八岁起就是当爸爸。我想把它进行到底。对。而且我必须权衡，正如我对它进行了认真的权衡。我在哪里能发挥最大的作用？我想享受自己。对它进行了认真的权衡。我在哪里能发挥最大的作用？
And I want to enjoy myself. It's hard work doesn't scare me. But I'm an artist, I'm a storyteller. I'm a folk singer. You know what I mean? Now, is those parts of me what could be useful in a political position of leadership to be a CEO of a state or a country?
并且我想享受自己。辛苦的工作吓不倒我。但我是一个艺术家，我是一个讲故事的人。我是一个民谣歌手。你知道我的意思吗？现在，我身上那些能够在一个州或一个国家的政治领导职位上发挥作用的部分——成为一个州或国家的首席执行官——
Maybe, but some things to, you know, I'm raising my three kids right now, is a hard but fair fight. Going into politics right now is a hard and unfair fight. I'm trying to win, let me go, let me go win my priority non-negotiable fair fight. Yeah.
也许可以，但有些事情，你知道的，我现在抚养三个孩子，这是一场艰难但公平的战斗。现在投身政治是一场艰难且不公平的战斗。我正试图去赢，让我去，让我去赢得我那优先的、不可妥协的公平战斗。对。
First, and then let me out back and have a high-fripp. And forget me go win my priority non-negotiable fair fight. Yeah. First, and then let me out back and have it. And forget me for asking, I just, it's just, I just think you'd be incredible. I don't mind, I don't mind at all. It's a great answer. It is. And I think we kind of made a little bit of news. So in 10 years, you got a 10 year old.
首先，然后让我到后面去击掌庆祝。原谅我去赢得我那优先的、不可妥协的公平战斗。对。首先，然后让我到后面去击掌。原谅我多问一句，我只是，我只是觉得你会非常不可思议。我不介意，我一点也不介意。这是一个很棒的回答。确实如此。而且我觉得我们好像刚刚爆了一点新闻。所以10年后，你有一个10岁的孩子。
Eight years, really. Yeah. You'll be on the ticket somewhere. Yeah. So there we have it. Can I just say something more, because I I've said this too, personally, okay. But I want to bring it up to y'all, because y'all probably closer with him
8年，真的。对。你会在某个选票上出现。对。所以就这样。我能再多说几句吗，因为我自己也这样说过，个人而言。但我很想跟你们提一下，因为你们可能和他更亲近，
and you'll know what I'm talking about. But the man in the bottom right corner who is so technically adept today, and he's so prudent. I'm so, I've always loved him, loved him in comedy. But I was so happy to see him get into drama. Yeah. Because, does anyone have a better delayed blank?
而且你们会明白我在说什么。就是右下角的那个男人，他今天技术如此娴熟，而且如此谨慎。我非常，我一直很喜欢他，喜欢他在喜剧中的表现。但我很高兴看到他涉足正剧。对。因为，有人能做出比他更棒的延迟眨眼吗？
The Jason Bateman? He's got the best, Bateman's got the best delayed blank in the business. That's great. That's great. I introduced a half blank to a character about a year ago. I did it for some of the other night. It's a party. I totally forgot about it.
杰森·贝特曼？他有最棒的，贝特曼拥有业内最棒的延迟眨眼。太棒了。太棒了。我大约在一年前在一个角色身上引入了半个眨眼。我前几天还为别的角色做过。那是在一个派对上。我完全忘了这事。
It's like this really affected kind of, what Winks are super douchey anyway, but I took it up a notch for a half-wink. The lids don't actually close. It's just sort of like a little, a little, a little, a a little exaggerated like squit. Oh, it's fucking terrible. I also keep forgetting to incorporate close-eyed talking with a character. That's also super douchey. You know what someone close- Madonna did that. Closes their eyes when they talk. No, you know what? You just don't understand what I'm saying. Yeah, close-
这就像这种真的很做作的，眨眼本身就已经超级做作了，但我把它升级到了半个眨眼。眼睑其实并没有完全闭上。它只是那种像有点儿，有点儿，有点儿，有点儿夸张的眯眼。哦，太他妈糟糕了。我还总是忘记在一个角色身上加入闭眼说话。那也超级做作。你知道有谁闭着眼——麦当娜就这样。说话时闭着眼睛。不，你知道吗？你只是不明白我在说什么。对，闭—
right? Yeah. That's a good one. But thank you. Thank you. A lot of people close them slow, but then they get nervous on the rebound and open them quick. You close them slow, and I think you open them slower. And it's right between, I got to hang on every word, and he's absolutely fucking with Bidney. I think a lot of it's ZX, too, isn't it? It's a lot of ZX.
对吧？对。这是一个好把戏。但谢谢你。谢谢。很多人闭得很慢，但在反弹时又会紧张，迅速睁开。你闭得很慢，而我觉得你睁得更慢。它恰好介于“我必须铭记他的每一个字”和“他绝对是在瞎胡闹”之间。我觉得很大一部分也是ZX，对吧？有很大一部分ZX。
I'm also in the editing room. So I'm in freeze frames all the time. Just to elongate the eye clothes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, man, God. Well, we're over. We're eight minutes over. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
我也在剪辑室里。所以我一直都在处理定格画面。只是为了拉长闭眼的时间。对，对，对。哦，天哪，老天。好吧，我们超时了。我们超时了八分钟。对，对，对，对。
We're generous for being there. Listen, man, yeah, thank you for coming back our first returning guest. Yes. For giving me another shot with my hot head. I appreciate you. We only made it through pre-production last time, but that's true. We're producing it through this time. Yeah.
我们能留在那儿已经很大方了。听着，老兄，对，谢谢你回来，我们的第一位回头客。是的。谢谢你给我这个脾气暴躁的人另一次机会。我很感激你。我们上次只拍到前期制作就结束了，但那是真的。我们这次把它制作完成了。对。
Yeah. What an absolute treat, man. It's so great to have you so much. Yeah, you're such a great person. Appreciate it. Yeah, I appreciate it. Yeah, and all the success in your book, it comes out just because September 12th,
对，绝对是一种享受，老兄。非常高兴能邀请到你。对，你是一个如此棒的人。我很感激。对，我很感激。对，祝你的新书大卖，它将在9月12日发行，
am I right about that? I think that's right. I'm not sure. I don't have it over there. I'll be out there. I'm talking about it. September 12th. Am I right about that? I think that's right. I'm not sure. I don't have it over there. I'll be out there talking about it. September 12th. September 12th. Just because Matthew,
我没记错吧？我想是这样的。我不确定。我手头没有。我会去宣传的。我在谈论它。9月12日。我没记错吧？我想是这样的。我不确定。我手头没有。我会去宣传的。9月12日。9月12日。因为马修，
hey, man. You're the man. You are the man. Man, appreciate it. Okay, thank you. Thank you, Pat. Thank you so much. Bless up.
嘿，老兄。你真行。你太棒了。老兄，很感激。好的，谢谢你。谢谢你，帕特。非常感谢。祝一切顺利。
Bye, buddy. Oh, love him. Real good. I tell you what, I like that, Matt McConaughey. Yeah, I could talk to him. It's not Matt. It's Matthew.
再见，伙计。哦，太喜欢他了。真不错。我跟你说，我喜欢那个，马修·麦康纳。对，我能和他聊聊。不是马修（Matthew），是马修（Matthew）。
I know. Yeah. I made that mistake once. It's not marable. I know. I know. He talked to him from a man. Wait out.
我知道。对。我犯过一次那种错误。不是玛拉堡。我知道。我知道。他和一个男人交谈。等等。
What a guy. Really? He is an absolute original. He does not waver. He doesn't says what he wants. His roles have been all over the place from the sort of the easiest go down sort of popcorn kind of films to the most challenging artistic films,
真是个家伙。真的吗？他绝对是个原创人物。他从不退缩。他从不，他想说什么就说什么。他的角色跨度非常广泛，从那种最容易下咽的爆米花电影到最具挑战性的艺术电影，
small budget things, and then also just like, I love that he lives super down home there in Texas, but then he also lives a very flamboyant and elite lifestyle as well. He just, he figures out a way to manage it all. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, he's, but what he's been able to do in, in starting out is kind of a matinee idol and, and, and sort of hanging in there, not forcing people to appreciate
小成本制作，然后还有那种，我喜欢他在德克萨斯过着非常朴实无华的生活，但同时他也过着非常奢华和精英式的生活。他只是，他找到了管理这一切的方法。对。对。不管怎样，他在刚出道时是一个银幕偶像，并且一直坚持下来，没有强迫人们去欣赏
or respect his, his acting chops, you know, like you didn't cram some, you know, Shakespeare thing down our throat right after some romcom, like he's, he's, he's never by the way. And what I like also is he talks about. He just shows, he's like, for the most part, he just shows up on Friday night. That's where you can see him on a Friday night when the movie opens. And he's not out there going talking about his process. In this way that self-aggrandizing, he just does it.
或尊重他的演技，你知道的，就像他没有在某个浪漫喜剧之后强行把什么莎士比亚的东西塞进我们喉咙一样，他从来没有，顺便说一句。我喜欢的一点是，他谈论。他只是展示，他就像，在大多数情况下，他只在周五晚上现身。那是你在周五电影上映时能看到他的地方。他并没有到处去大谈特谈他的创作过程。以那种自吹自擂的方式，他只是去做。
He just does it. But you know what I loved? I loved when he said, he's so great at everything he does, that even when he was saying he was signing off, he even, it was even cool the way he waved. Good. Bye. It's really a creative one.
他只是去做。但你知道我最喜欢什么吗？我喜欢当他说，他在他做的每件事上都那么棒，以至于当他说他要告别时，他甚至连挥手道别的方式都那么酷。好。再见。真是个有创意的人。
I don't know. Literally saying bye. Sean always wants to get out. He's one of the other shots. I was, Sean's always asked like there was like a cat running out with the meter running outside. Like he's just got a like, maybe there is. Maybe there. There probably isn't Broadway is right outside.
我不知道。字面上的再见。肖恩总是想离开。他是另一个赶时间的人。我当时，肖恩总是问，就像外面有只带着字跳动的计价器在跑的猫一样。就像他只是有一个——也许真的有。也许吧。可能没有吧，百老汇就在外面。
All right. Hey, listen, listen, listen there. I love you. Go. Go. Bye. We love you. Listen, we're just going to do something.
好了。嘿，听着，听着，听着。我爱你。走吧。走吧。再见。我们爱你。听着，我们要做点事。
Bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjurf. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Every big moment starts with a big dream.
再见。再见。SmartLess是由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Amjurf100%有机纯手工打造的。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry App上的Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。每一个伟大的时刻都始于一个伟大的梦想。
But what happens when that big dream turns out to be a big flop. From Wondry and Atwell Media, I'm Misha Brown and this is the big flop. Every week, comedians join me to chronicle the biggest flugs, fails and blunders of all time like Quibi. It's kind of like when you give yourself your own nickname and you try to like get other people to do it. And the 2019 movie adaptation of Cats. Like if I'm watching the dancing and I'm noticing the feet aren't touching the ground, there's something wrong with the movie. Find out what happens when Massive Hype turns into Major Fiasco.
但是，当那个伟大的梦想变成一场彻底的惨败时，会发生什么呢？来自Wondry和Atwell Media，我是Misha Brown，这里是大惨败。每周，喜剧演员们都会和我一起记录史上最大的惨败、失败和失误，比如Quibi。这有点像当你给自己起了一个外壳，然后你试图让其他人也这么叫。以及2019年的电影改编版《猫》。就像如果我在看舞蹈，而我注意到脚没有着地，这电影就肯定有问题。来看看当巨大的宣传变成巨大的惨败时会发生什么。
Enjoy the Big Flop on the Wondery app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early and ad-free on Wondery Plus. Get started with your free trial at Wondery.com slash plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Wondry App上享受《大惨败》，或者在你的任何播客平台上收听。你可以在Wondry Plus上提前且无广告地收听《大惨败》。访问Wondry.com/plus开始你的免费试用。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。